BUDGET.
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO ON
EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY WE HAVE
SOME MISCELLANEOUS ITEMS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND WE WILL START WITH ISSUE THE
FIRST ISSUE WITH -- DEPARTMENT
OF ED.
AND WHO'S FROM.
YES THIS THE THE ISSUE IS ADULT
EDUCATION SO WE HAVE COMING UP
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TERMINA FINANCE ADELIA PLEASE
COME UP.
IT'S GOING TO GO FIRST.
OKAY FIRST [inaudible]
YES.
AND WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
LA OUT.
THANK YOU THE SICKENING WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE MUST FIND OVERVIEW OF ADULT
EDUCATION IS CONTEXT FOR THIS
ISSUE.
THE SERGEANTS ARE DISTRIBUTING
HAND OUT THAT WILL BE SPEAKING
FROM.
WHAT DO YOU SEE THE HAND OUT
YOU'LL SEE ON THE FIRST PAGE
THAT THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF
ADULT EDUCATION IS TO PROVIDE
ADULTS WITH PRE COLLEGIATE
KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND ABILITIES?
AND TO THAT END THE MAIN
INSTRUCTIONAL AREAS AND IT'LL
THAT CONSIST OF BASIC ENGLISH
MATH.
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE AND
ALSO SHORT TERM C. D. E..
IN CALIFORNIA THE MAIN PROVIDERS
OF ADULT EDUCATION OUR ADULT
SCHOOLS OPERATED BY K. TWELVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SYSTEM.
HISTORICALLY THESE TWO SYSTEMS
OF OPERATED SEPARATELY BUT BACK
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN IN
RESPONSE TO CONCERNS ABOUT LACK
OF COORDINATION ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT PROVIDER TYPES.
THE STATE RESTRUCTURED ADULT ADD
AROUND A SYSTEM REGIONAL
CONSORTIA.
THE COMBINED BOTH ADULTS SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
CURRENTLY THERE SEVENTY ONE OF
THESE REGIONAL ADULT EDUCATION
CONSORTIA ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THE ROUGHLY NOT TO THAT
SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
THE STATE IS PROVIDING A ONGOING
FUNDING.
OFFICIALLY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
STARTING IN. TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN FOR INSTRUCTION AT THE
ADULT SCHOOLS AND NON
CONSTRUCTION THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT SOME
ADULT EDUCATION FIGHTERS DO ALSO
RECEIVE OTHER FUNDING SOURCES SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THEY RECEIVE
APPORTIONMENT FOR THEIR NON
CREDIT ADULT COURSES.
AND BOTH ADULTS SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SOMETIMES
RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING.
YOU'LL RECALL THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE STATE DID
AUGMENT FUNDING FOR THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM PREVIOUSLY
KNOWN AS THE ADULT EDUCATION
BLOCK GRANT.
THE BULK OF THIS AUGMENTATION
TWENTY TWO MILLION WAS FOR A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE PROGRAM
WAS CREATED IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE
REMAINING FIVE MILLION ONGOING
AUGMENTATION WAS FOR DATA
IMPROVEMENTS.
COMBINED WITH AN ADDITIONAL DATA
REQUIREMENTS THESE WERE INTENDED
TO FACILITATE THE TRACKING OF
STUDENT OUTCOMES ACROSS PROVIDER
TYPES AND ASTON CENTER THE WORK
FORCE.
THIS YEAR IS YOUR CAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING AN
ADDITIONAL COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
WHAT YOU BRING TOTAL FUNDING FOR
THE ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM TO
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION ON GOING?
INCLUDE -- OVERVIEW WE WANTED
NOTED A FEW UNRESOLVED ISSUES IN
THE STATE'S ADULT EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
AS WE HAVE NOTED BEFORE WHEN THE
STATE RESTRUCTURED AT ALL ADD IT
WAS WITH THE GOAL OF BRINGING
TOGETHER TWO SEPARATE SYSTEMS.
AND WHILE THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
EFFORTS TO BETTER LINE IS TO
SYSTEMS THERE ARE A FEW OF
REMAINING UNRESOLVED ISSUES. ONE
OF THESE ISSUES HAS TO DO WITH
FUNDING BECAUSE THE STATE DOES
NOT HAVE A PER STUDENT FUNDING
RATE.
THAT'S DESIGNATED ACROSS
PROVIDER TYPES THERE IS LIKELY
VARIATION IN FUNDING LEVELS
PURPOSE ACROSS PROVIDERS.
WHICH MAY RESULT IN DIFFERENCES
IN ACCESS AND QUALITY ACROSS THE
STATE.
THERE ALSO SOME POLICIES THAT
ARE DIFFERENT BETWEEN THAT ALL
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY POLICIES
RELATED TO COURSE FEES AN
INSTRUCTOR QUALIFICATIONS.
AND FINALLY THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS WITH THE
DATA THAT'S AVAILABLE AND
STUDENT OUTCOMES.
SINCE RESTRUCTURING IT ALL AT
SYSTEM THERE HAS NOT BEEN
CONFERENCE A DATE ON THIS WHICH
HAS MADE IT CHALLENGING.
TO EVALUATE WHETHER IT'S
SPENDING ON THE PROGRAM HAS
ACHIEVED ITS DESIRED RESULTS.
THAT BEING SAID I HAD THE
DEPARTMENTS OF INDICATED TO US
THAT IMPROVEMENTS ARE UNDERWAY
AND I BELIEVE WILL BE CARRYING
FROM THEM LATER ON THIS PANEL.
ON THE PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN MADE.
THANK A CRUISER OVERVIEW AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU KEITH IS ON DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES OVER SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
FUNDING FOR THREE PRIMARY ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR POINT SIX MILLION OF
WHICH IS FROM PROPOSITION I
GENERAL PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND -- FOR THEBUT THE
MAIN ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM
JOINTLY ADMINISTERED BY THE
COMMITTEE CALL CHANCES OFFICE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
THERE'S FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE ADULT IN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
AND A HUNDRED APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED FOUR MILLION IN FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR TITLE TO WORKFORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITIES ACT AND
CAL WORKS AT ALL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A PORTION
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND K.
TWELVE PORTION IS THAT ALSO
SERVE -- THE ADULT EDUCATION A
STUDENT DEMOGRAPHIC -- OF THE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS NOTED ABOVE
EIGHTEEN MILLION -- IS THE COLOR
FOR THE DAHLE EDUCATION PROGRAM
AND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
IS A COLA FOR THE ADULTS IN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
YES SO I WOULD LIKE TO REPORT
OUT THAT -- THAT WE ACTUALLY OUR
WONDERFUL BECAUSE MY COMMENTS ON
THE ISSUE OF THE THE DATA.
AND THE PERFORMANCE WE'VE
ACTUALLY OR SEEN INCREASES AND
PERFORMANCE.
OUR WE'RE TRACKING PERFORMANCE
THROUGH THE PROGRAM AREAS AND
WERE SEEN INCREASES WE ALWAYS
SEE AN INCREASE OF 10%.
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED THE PAST WE ARE.
INCREASING OUR ACTUALLY A
IMPROVING UPON A DAY REPORTING
YOU'LL FIND WHEN YOU SEE THE
ACTUAL AND A REPORT FOR THIS
YEAR.
THAT WE DID NOT HAVE IN THE
PRIOR YEAR'S OUTCOME SUCH AS
TRANSITIONS INTO POST SECONDARY
OR DID WE DO WE CAN HAVE THE
WORK FORCE OUTCOMES SUCH AS
MEDIAN WAGE AND WAGE GAINS -- SO
NOW YOU'LL SEE THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE DATED REPORT OUT THOUGH SO
WE ARE IMPROVING UPON THOSE
AREAS -- YES OF FOR EXAMPLE WE
ACTUALLY HAD.
US THE LIKELY.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE THE COUNT
OF STUDENTS WITH SIX HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND WE ACTUALLY
INCREASE AT THE SEVEN EIGHT
SIXTY THREE THOUSAND WHICH WAS.
A 10% INCREASE AND WE ACTUALLY
HAVE OUTCOMES.
AND ALL THE OPERABLE PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE AREAS -- GOOD
MORNING.
BUDGET CHAIR MCCARTY IN MEMBERS
I AM DOCTOR CAROLINE'S ACT READ
MINISTRY -- OF THE ADULT
EDUCATION OFFICE TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND.
THIS WEEK HAPPENS TO BE ADULT
EDUCATION WEEK SO AS A HEARING
ON THIS TOPIC IT'S VERY TIMELY.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE PACKED
AUDIENCE IN THE BACK MANY OF OUR
ADULT ED FOLKS ARE HERE TODAY.
MISSION OF THE ADULT EDUCATION
OFFICES TO DELIVER ASSISTANCE
AND GUIDANCE TO PROVIDERS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ADULT
EDUCATION.
AS IT SERVES CALIFORNIANS.
ADULT EDUCATION OFFICE MONITORS
AND OVERSEES THE TITLE TO ADULT
EDUCATION FAMILY LITERACY ACT
WHICH IS PART OF THE FEDERAL
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDER IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THE TITLE TO DOLLARS PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDERS IN ADDITION
THE ADULT EDUCATION OFFICE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
COLLEGE THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCES OFFICE JOINTLY
ADMINISTER AS WAS SHARE EARLIER
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH EDUCATION
PROGRAM PROVIDING ADULT
EDUCATION SERVICES TO REGIONAL
CONSORTIA THROUGHOUT.
THE STATE WE RECENTLY SENT OVER
A DRAFT OF THE ANNUAL END OF THE
YEAR REPORT.
REPORTED DRESSES SOME KEY
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS STATE LEVEL
DATA ON STUDENT ENROLLMENT
OUTCOMES SKILL GAINES STUDENT
DEMOGRAPHICS AND OTHER DATA
USING THE ADULT EDUCATION DATA
AND ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS.
AND ARE AS WELL AS OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE ON
THE REPORT.
THAT'S NOT GOING.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF ORDER TODAY.
I KNOW THERE IS THAT ADULT
EDUCATION CONTINGENT HERE AND
THEY ASKED.
THEY SAID LOOK WE'RE GONNA WE
COULD SPEAK FOR THIRTY MINUTES
AT THE END. THIRTY PEOPLE AT ONE
MINUTE OR WE CAN DO A THREE
MINUTE PRESENTATION SO I THOUGHT
IT WAS A FAIR TRADE.
SO SO SO WITH THAT -- GOING TO
BRING AT DON KEPT KEY WITH THE
ASSOCIATION TO GIVE US A
PRESENTATION ON ADULT EDUCATION.
AND THEN OF ALL WILL HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AND SOME QUESTIONS
AFTER YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DON KHAKI MCCUE CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR ADULT
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
EDUCATION ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION.
APPRECIATES OUR THE OPPORTUNITY --
ADULT EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT -- SYSTEM
FOR I SERVING SOME OF THE MOST
MARGINALIZED AMONG OUR
COMMUNITIES I AS WAS MENTIONED
WE DO PROGRAMMING IN ESL
CITIZENSHIP BASIC SKILLS ARE
CAREER TRAINING -- AND MUCH MORE
FAMILY LITERACY AND IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT THAT ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS AND STUDENTS WE SERVE I
FIT TO DIRECTLY INTO THE
PRIORITIES YOU HAVE A LEAD AS
THE LEGISLATURE.
HI I HAVE IDENTIFIED A WHETHER
THAT'S IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IN THE SUPPORT THAT WE
PROVIDE TO THOSE PARENTS --
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION -- AS WELL
CITIZENSHIP ESL OF FOR OUR
STUDENTS LOOKING FOR THE PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP I AND BASIC SKILLS
AND SUPPORT FOR SHORT TERM
CAREER TRAINING I'VE FOR THOSE.
LOOKING TO ADD TO RETOOL AND ME
ON THE FIND A NEW OPPORTUNITIES
IN CAREER OR FOR TRANSITIONS --
TO WORK WITH THEM ON BASIC
SKILLS TO TRANSITION THEM TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGEPARTNERS --
AND HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS ARE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ADDITION AND
INCLUSION OF A COAL -- BY THE
ADMINISTRATION A VERY POSITIVE --
WE DO NOTE UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER
THAT WHILE POSITIVE THE ODD THAT
CHOCOLATE IS NOT ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THE INCREASING COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SALARY PENSION
COSTS WHAT HAVE YOU.
I'LL BULLARD ABOUT THREE POINT
4% -- WHERE IS WERE SEEN OUR
TOLL SCHOOL STRUGGLE WITH COST
INCREASES EACH YEAR BETWEEN FIVE
AND 9% BASED ON -- KIND OF
VARYING FACTORS EACH DISTRICT IS
AS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT BUT THE
POINT BEING THE COAL IS NOT
COVERING THOSE COST INCREASES.
AS WAS MENTIONED -- ALTHOUGH
SOME OF OUR ADULT SCHOOLS DO YOU
RECEIVE SOME FEDERAL FUNDING --
MOST OF THEM ARE RELYING SOLELY
ON THE ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM
DOLLARS WHICH MEANS WITH RISING
COSTS AND BAO COLA THAT DOESN'T
COVER THOSE RISING COSTS.
THEY FIND THEMSELVES IN
CHALLENGING POSITIONS TO HAVE TO
MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS AROUND
PROGRAMMING -- AND CUTS TO
PROGRAMMING TO BACK FILL THOSE
RISING COSTS SO THE RESULT IS IS
THAT FEWER OPTIONS ARE GOING
FORWARD IN TERMS OF SERVING.
THE STUDENTS THAT ARE THE MOST
MORE MARGINALIZED -- WHO NEED
THESE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES I TO
KIND OF LIFT THEMSELVES UP
SUPPORT THEIR K. TWELVE AND
EARLY CHILDHOOD LEARNER WHAT
HAVE YOU SO WITH THAT WE HAVE
PUTS I RESPECTFULLY ON THE TABLE?
A PROPOSAL FOR A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR%
THE ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM.
THE THOUGHT THERE IS THAT WE
WOULD BE USING THIRTY MILLION OF
THAT I TO FOCUS ON HARD TO SERVE
POPULATIONS WITH SOME
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING.
WE REPRESENT THE Q. TWELVE ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDERS AND WE'RE
COMMITTED. TO DELIVERING ON
OUTCOMES AND BELIEVE THAT THE
DATA WILL SHOW THAT COMMITMENT
IN WORKING WITH -- THE CHAIR A
LAST YEAR ON IMPLEMENTING
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION METRICS TO
DEMONSTRATE OUR COMMITMENT TO
DELIVERING OUTCOMES AND
PROVIDING ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THESE RESOURCES.
THAT THIRTY MILLION WOULD BE
ANTI TO SOME PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING IN THAT REGARD.
AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION OF
THAT HUNDRED TEN WOULD GO
TOWARDS I'VE BEEN HELPING TO
ADDRESS ICTP FEES ARE TO
MINIMIZE SOME OF THERE'D BURDENS
ON OUR STUDENTS RELATIVE TO FEES
THAT WE HAVE NO WHERE ELSE TO
PULL FUNDING TO BACK FILL.
AND PROVIDE SOME GROWTH AND THEN
FINALLY A FIFTY MILLION OF THAT
HUNDRED TEND TO GO TOWARDS
RISING COSTS AS WELL AS ON
GROWING ACCESS FOR THE STUDENTS
THAT NEED AT CENSUS DATA.
SHOWS THAT WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF US ADULTS WHO NEED
BASIC SKILLS ESL WHAT HAVE YOU
AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS A
DEFENSIBLE NUMBER -- WE'VE
REALLY TRIED TO COME TO YOU WITH
A SUCH AND RELIGIOUS WOULD
ENCOURAGE BY THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE BROADER LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL FUNDING -- ABSENT TWO
DOTS ARE WE DO WANT TO ON GOING
CUTS TO PROGRAMMING BOTH IT IS
SEEN THEM ALREADY IN CURRENT
BUDGET YEAR -- BUT ALSO WHEN OUT
HERE SO WITH THAT SAID I REALLY
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BEYOND THE COLA.
ON AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
SURE ALSO QUESTIONS FOR
DEPARTMENT A MAYBE JUST ONE FOR
THE THE ASSOCIATION HERE SO AS
PART OF YOUR REQUEST UNDERSTAND
IT'S THREE FOLD.
IT'S YOUR YOUR COSTS WITH YOUR
EMPLOYEES AND SO FORTH IN
RETIREMENT -- ENROLLMENT GROWTH
AND THEN THIS THAT TARGETED
PERFORMANCE BONUS SYSTEM SO ONE
OF THAT THE BIGGEST ISSUE FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS AS HIS -- HIS
ACCESS AND DURING THAT GREAT
RECESSION.
TREMENDOUS A LOSS OF ACCESS AND
SOME OF THESE.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA I
THINK THE BIGGEST SHOCKING ONE
WAS THE NUMBERS FROM LOS ANGELES
I FORGET THAT THE ACTUAL DETAILS
OF THAT -- AS FAR AS THE THAT
THE NUMBER BUT AND WE'RE GONNA
HEAR REPORT I'M ASKING SECOND
FROM THE DEPARTMENT BUT WHAT DO
YOU FROM YOUR MEMBERS -- TAG AS
THE UNMET NEED OUT THERE AS FAR
AS ACCESS ENROLLMENT IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION -- EACH OF THE
REGIONS GO THROUGH A PLANNING
PROCESS -- WITH A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PARTNERS THE ADULT
SCHOOLS AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHAT HAVE
YOU TO IDENTIFY THE UNMET NEED
IN EACH REGION OBVIOUSLY THAT
VARIES FROM REGION TO REGION.
I KNOW CENSUS DATA PRIOR TO
CATEGORICAL FLEXIBILITY -- WHEN
WE WERE FUNDED JUST AS A KEY
TWELVE SYSTEM AT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ALONE INDICATED
THERE WAS FIRE THERE WERE FIVE
MILLION ADULTS IN NEED OF BASIC
SKILLS ON ESL?
WHAT HAVE YOU AND WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT NUMBER IS TO AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT TODAY I THINK
THE DEPARTMENTS AND PERHAPS
OTHER CHANCES OFFICE COULD SPEAK
TO KIND OF?
MORE UPDATED NUMBERS -- BUT THEY
DID UNMET NEED A SIGNIFICANT
STILL IN THE STATE.
PARTICULARLY -- WERE LOOKING OUT
KIND OF THE NEEDS OF OUR KIND OF
OUR HOMELESS POPULATION WE ARE
SEEN.
HOMELESS ADULTS ARE GROWING AND
MANY OF OUR TOLL SCHOOLS ARE
SERVING -- HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
WITH OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENT CAREER TRAINING
WHICH IS VERY POSITIVE
ADDITIONALLY ARE GIVEN FEDERAL
POLICIES AROUND IMMIGRATION ARE
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE CITIZENSHIP
PATHWAYS YOURSELF FOR THOSE IN
NEED OF THAT -- SO IN TERMS OF
THE NEED TO AYE IT'S DEFINITELY
SIGNIFICANT I BELIEVE IN AND
AROUND KIND OF THE FIVE MILLION
MARK.
THANK YOU FOR THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BABY DEPARTMENT AT THAT AT FIRST
THERE IS THAT REPORT COMING.
SHORTLY AS FAR AS THAT THE THE
YOU'RE IN A REPORT.
CORRECT GAS INDIAN AND NEED SO
THAT.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING DIFFERENT
IN PRIOR YEARS AS FAR AS MONEY
TO HAVE IN THE BUDGET AND ACCESS
ISSUES ACROSS THE STATE.
SO RIGHT NOW THE REPORT IS IN
DRAFT FORM IT'S THE JOINTLY
JOINTLY -- PUT TOGETHER BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND WE DID SEND OVER A DRAFT
PART OF THAT.
WHAT THE REPORT WILL SHOW --
WON'T HAVE SPECIFIC DATA ON THE
NEED BECAUSE RIGHT NOW OUR
CONSORTIA WORKING ON THEIR THREE
YEAR PLANS AND PART OF THAT.
THREE YEAR PLANNING PROCESS IS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
OUT WHAT THEIR CURRENT NEED IS
WITHIN THEIR REGION WILL BE ABLE
TO PULL THAT DATA OUT FROM THEIR
THREE YEAR PLANS WHICH ARE DUE.
IN AT THE BEGINNING OF JUNE OKAY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHAT'S THE QUESTION ABOUT THAT
THE CAPACITY IN THE NEED I MEAN
OUT I KNOW WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET
AND THAT'S FRANKLY WHAT YOU HAD
PROP NINETY EIGHT BUT BUT DO YOU
THINK THAT THERE IS -- UNMET
NEED OUT THERE FOR ADULT
EDUCATION OF OUR THAT WE ARE NOT
ABLE.
TO TACKLE WITH OUR WITH OUR
BUDGET APPROPRIATION.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE BY
THE REASON THERE'S THERE'S
SEVERAL REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED IN REQUIRED YOU HAVE TO
BE SUBMITTED FRONT JOINTLY FROM
DEPARTMENT OCCASION IN THE
CHANCES OFFICE FIRST TO ASSESS.
YOU KNOW THOSE TYPES OF METRICS
IN TERMS OF NEED DEMAND --
OUTCOMES -- SO WE ARE ALSO GOING
TO AWAITING THAT DATA INTO AND
WE'LL TAKE THAT DATA INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE DEVELOP THE
YOU KNOW THE MAY REVISION --
WILL BE DEFINITELY -- ARE OPEN
TO CONSIDERING ALL ALL
INFORMATION TERMS OF DEMAND IN
THE OKAY THANK YOU AND AND JUST --
YOU KNOW I I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE AND I SUPPORTED.
ADULT EDUCATION -- INVESTMENT
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND YOU KNOW
THIS HAS A COLON THERE WHICH IS
A GOOD THING AND I CERTAINLY
WANT TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
LOWER OUR OVERALL ACCESS -- YOU
KNOW ADULT EDUCATION SERVES SO
MANY CAPACITIES FOR YOU KNOW
PEOPLE FOCUSING ON BASIC SKILLS --
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AS WE
HEARD -- NOW ENGLISH LANGUAGE --
CERTAINLY CREDIT RECOVERY AND
YOU KNOW US.
I'LL SAY IT AGAIN I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE OF ADULT EDUCATION SOME
PEOPLE ARE SURPRISED.
YES AND BY THE WAY HAPPY ADULT
EDUCATION WEEK SO I AM CERTAINLY
NOT PROUD THAT IN MY FINAL YEAR
OF HIGH SCHOOL AT A POINT.
EIGHT GPA THAT'S NOT A MISTAKE
POINT EIGHT ZERO AND IT LANDED
ME IN WINTER STEEN ADULT SCHOOL.
ABOUT FIVE MILES DOWN THE ROAD
AND ARMED FOR MALL BUT BECAUSE
OF THAT HELP ME GET MY ACT
TOGETHER AND AND HELP ME TO
ENROLL YOUR SO LATER IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I WENT DOWN LATER TO LONG BEACH
STATE TWENTY MISTER DONILON BACK
HERE TODAY SO ADULT EDUCATION
SERVICE.
ALL KINDS OF CALIFORNIANS AND
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF MY
EXPERIENCE BUT I I KNOW FIRST
HAND THE VALUE.
OF ADULT DAD SO WE'LL BE LOOKING --
TO TO TO REINVEST AND MAKE SURE
WE SERVE.
CALIFORNIANS WHO WHO NEED THAT
TAXES SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT WITH THE MERRY VISE
AND AS WELL AS WHAT -- WE HAVE
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET AS WELL SO WILL
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE PROCEED ISSUE NUMBER
.
TWO OKAY ONCE AGAIN WILL HAVE LA
US START LA UP.
IN JAIL.
THE SERGEANTS DISTRIBUTED
SECONDHAND OUT THAT WILL BE
SEEKING FROM FOR THIS ISSUE THIS
PROVIDES SAID BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE CALVIN CAN COLLEGES STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
HE NEVER CALLED STRONG WORK
FIRST PROGRAM GRANT OF THAT.
TASK FORCE THAT DAY SEE SEE SEE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS COMMISSIONED
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ON IMPROVING
CITY.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS TASK FORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE STATE
CREATED THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM WITH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING THE AVAILABILITY AND
QUALITY OF C. T. ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND ALSO IMPROVING THE ALIGNMENT
OF C. T. PROGRAMS WITH REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
CURRENTLY THE STATE PROVIDES TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
ONGOING FOR THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THIS AMOUNT SUPPLEMENT THE
PORTION FUNDING FOR THE STATE
ALSO PROVIDES FOR CITY
INSTRUCTION THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THE INTENT IS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
SOME CITY PROGRAMS HAVE HIGHER
INSTRUCTIONAL COSTS RELATED TO
SMALLER CLASS SIZES IN EXPENSIVE
EQUIPMENT.
AND ALSO TO FACILITATE THE
REGIONAL PLANNING AND
COORDINATION THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS STRUCTURED AROUND.
ON THE SECOND PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT WE'VE DETAILED WHAT THIS
FOR THE STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY DIVIDED INTO EIGHT
REGIONAL CONSORTIA OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THESE ARE DIFFERENT FROM THAT AT
ALL AND REGIONAL CONSORTIA WE
DISCUSSED IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL.
THE STRONG WORK FORCE CONSORTIA
ARE.
CONSISTING OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
COLLABORATE WITH REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR IT'S AN INDUSTRY
LEADERS. TO DEVELOP REGIONAL
PLANS.
THEY'RE ALSO REQUIRED TO USE
LABOR MARKET DATA TO IDENTIFY
PRIORITY INDUSTRY SECTORS IN
WHICH TO SPEND THEIR STRONG WORK
FORCE FUND.
CURRENTLY FUNDING FOR EACH
REGIONAL CONSORTIUM IS ALLOCATED
BY FORMULA THE TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT CITY ENROLLMENTS IN THE
REGION AS WELL AS ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS.
AND STARTING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THERE'S ALSO BEEN A
PERFORMANCE SPACE COMPONENT OF
THIS FUNDING FORMULA.
FINALLY THE BOTTOM FOR HAND OUT
WE EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENS THE
FUNDS ONCE THAT ALLOCATED TO
EACH REGIONAL CONSORTIUM.
IN BRIEF 60% OF EACH REGIONAL
CONCESSIONS ALLOCATION GOES
DIRECTLY TO THE DISTRICTS WHERE
IS THE REMAINING 40% IS
ALLOCATED TO CONSORTIUM WHICH
HAS DISCRETION ON HOW BEST TO
USE THEM FOR REGIONAL PRIORITIES.
INCLUDES OUR OVERVIEW OF STRONG
WORK FIRST PROGRAM COLLEGES AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BERMAN OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
MACHON NEW AND WITH THE PART.
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FROM
WORKFORCE PROGRAM -- WHICH IS
THE SAME LEVEL OF FUNDING AS FOR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MADE A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO SWAP
SOME OF THE ALLOCATION FOR RE
APPROPRIATED AND SETTLE UP FUNDS
TO REFLECT AVAILABLE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WE'LL BE MONITORING REVENUES AND
THE LEVEL OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE AS WE APPROACHED.
OKAY SURE [inaudible]
IS BETTER.
WE WILL BE MONITORING REVENUES
AND THE LEVEL OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE AS WE APPROACH THE
MAYOR VISION BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INTENDS TO CONTINUE TO
FIND.
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM AT
ITS EXISTING LEVEL OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
CHAIRPERSON MCCARTY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON MATTHEW
ROBERTS I'M WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OVERSEEING STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM -- I HAVE A HANDOUT THAT
I HAVE GIVEN YOU A PASSED OUT IN
ITS THE POWER POINT -- THAT WILL
GO OVER SOME OF THE METRICS ON
SOME OF THE OUTCOMES THAT.
HAVE BEEN SORT OF TALKED ABOUT
SO FAR TODAY -- FIRST OF ALL
THOUGH LET ME JUST JUMP IN AND
SAY THAT -- THE CHANCES OFFICE --
IS HAS ROLLED OUT THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS AND THE SUCCESS METRICS
OF WHICH THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM OUTCOMES AND METRICS
WILL ALIGN AND SORT OF ROLL UP --
TO THE THE WITH THE OUTCOMES FOR
STRONG WORK FORCE ARE STILL
INTACT BUT THERE IS DEFINITELY
AN ALIGNMENT TO ENSURE THAT THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS -- IS
ACHIEVED THROUGH THE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PROGRAM SO --
THE WORK FIRST DEVELOPMENT
MISSIONS GOING ON TO PAGE THREE
REALLY TALKS ABOUT.
THE TYPES OF STUDENTS THAT WERE
AFTER MUCH OF WHAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT TODAY WITH ADULT ED TYPES
OF STUDENTS -- WE REALLY FOCUS
ON DEGREE AND TRANSFER STUDENTS
SEEKING STUDENTS SHORT TERM
CAREER EDUCATION STUDENTS.
AND THOSE ARE STUDENTS THAT COME
TO US FOR ONE OR TWO COURSES
SEEKING A CERTIFICATE A SHORT
TERM CERTIFICATE OR TO UP SKILL --
AND THEN ALSO ON BOARDING AN OFF
BOARDING WITH THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM SO WE'RE HAPPY
THAT THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM IS PROVIDED THOSE
AVENUES FOR CAREER EDUCATION --
MOVING ON TO THE METRICS
THEMSELVES ON THE PAGE -- FOR
THESE ARE CAREER EDUCATION FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS WHAT I
WANT TO POINT OUT IN THE CHARTS
THAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE IS ON
THE VERY RIGHT HAND SIDE THERE'S
A GOLDEN.
VERTICAL LINE THAT WAS AS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF STRONG
WORKFORCE AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
AND SO THE EFFECTS OF THE DATA
AFTER THAT LINE WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE TO SAY THAT THESE
WERE.
SORT OF FIELD BY STRONG
WORKFORCE YOU CAN SEE THE FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENT.
FOR OVERTIME FOR CAREER
EDUCATION HAS INCREASED FROM --
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FROM EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
EIGHT SIXTY THREE I'M NOT GONNA
READ THESE TO YOU INDIVIDUALLY
BUT CAREER EDUCATION STUDENTS
EARNING A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE
OVER TIME.
ON THE NEXT ON THE NEXT SLIDE --
INCREASED IN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN BY ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
FROM 720-002-77000.
MOVING DOWN WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE EMPLOYMENT AND
EARNINGS OUTCOMES WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE THOSE COME IN -- THIS IS
A DATA SET THAT GOES MORE
PARTICULAR INTO THE SUCCESS
METRICS TO LOOK AT THIS.
AND SO THE THE SAMPLE GETS A
LITTLE BIT MORE FINE TUNE BUT
YOU CAN SEE THE THE HUGE
INCREASE IN -- NUMBER OF
STUDENTS EARNING AN ANNUAL
EARNINGS OF SHORT TERM CAREER
EDUCATION STUDENTS GOING UP FROM
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND TO FORTY
TWO THOUSAND SO ENSURING THAT
THAT THAT LIVABLE WAGE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE CONTINUING
TO TARGET AS PART OF THE
LEGISLATION.
THE SUCCESS METRICS ALSO TALK
ABOUT THE MEDIAN CHANGING SHORT
TERM CAREER EDUCATION EARNINGS
YOU CAN SEE IT'S A VERTICAL LINE
THAT SORT OF GOES UP TO THE
RIGHT FROM 51% 253% AND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE LAST ONE LITTLE
PRESENT IN TERMS OF DATA OR
SHORT TERM CAREER EDUCATION
STUDENTS TO ATTAIN.
THE LIVING WAGE YOU CAN SEE A
DRAMATIC INCREASE FROM 58% 262%
OVER THE TWO YEAR PERIOD OF TIME.
SO WE ARE SEEING.
DEFINITE SIGNS OF OF MOVEMENT IN
OUR SYSTEM ESPECIALLY ALONG C.
T. CREATING MORE AND BETTER --
CAREER EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS OF THEY CAN ACCESS.
WANT TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SLIDE THAT TALKS A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE THE REGION'S
THEMSELVES AND THE OUT THE LA --
PRESENTED SOME GREAT INFORMATION
ABOUT OUR REGION SO I WON'T GO
TOO DEEP.
BUT AVOIDING DUPLICATION
ENSURING THE COLLABORATION IS
TAKING PLACE AMONG THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS IN A REGIONAL
ECONOMY IS EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
AND TAKING PLACE -- WITH -- WITH
OTHER INITIATIVES SUCH AS K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE FOR
SEEING AN EVEN MORE DIVE DOWN
INTO THE INDIVIDUAL SUBREGIONS --
TO ENGAGE WITH MORE PARTICULAR --
STAKEHOLDER SO WE'RE HAPPY ABOUT
THAT AND ALL FOCUS ON THESE
OUTCOMES HOW DO WE GENERATE THE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE LABOR
MARKET INFORMATION DRIVEN.
BUT ALSO ATTAINING THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE'RE AFTER.
AND THE FOCUS ON EVIDENCE I
WON'T TAKE YOU THROUGH THE
REGION'S THEMSELVES I THINK YOU
YOU ALL SORT OF KNOW WHERE THE
REGIONS ARE BUT THERE IS A MAP
IN HERE JUST IN CASE.
TERMS OF REGIONAL NEEDS AN
INVESTMENTS LET ME JUST
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THESE
FAURIA NORTH FAR NORTH WHICH IS
SACRAMENTO -- TO THE TO THE
OREGON BORDER.
THE HIGHEST INVESTMENT FOR
STRONG WORK FORCE DOLLARS OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS HAS BEEN.
IN HEALTH 418% FOLLOWED BY --
AGRICULTURE WATER ENVIRONMENTAL
TECHNOLOGIES FOLLOWED BY
BUSINESS AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AND YOU CAN SEE OTHER ONES LIKE
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING.
ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION AND
LOGISTICS SO IN TERMS OF THE
SECTOR -- THE SECTOR DR --
STRONGWORK FORCES DEFINITELY
HAVING AN EFFECT SO THAT'S FOR
YOUR REFERENCE.
YOU KNOW THE ALLOCATION FORMULA
WHICH HAS BEEN SET OUT IN
LEGISLATION.
FUNDING BY REGIONS THE NICE
THING THAT.
I THINK THE BIGGEST THING THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE GOING
FORWARD IS THE STABILITY OF THE
FUNDING. TO ENSURE THAT THE
INVESTMENTS DO CONTINUE TO GO
OUT TO MOVE STUDENTS FORWARD AND
SO THAT'S I THINK IN TERMS OF
OUR OUR MISSION GOING FORWARD.
YOU ALSO HAVE EXPENDITURES BY
CATEGORY AS MORE OF A DRILL DOWN
TO YOU -- AND THEN ALSO THE USE
OF THE SET ASIDE FUNDS HAVE
REALLY HELPED US TO DRIVE THE
DATA SETS -- MAKING SURE THAT
THE DATA IS VISUALIZE WHICH BY
THE WAY.
LAUNCH FOR DATA IS SOMETHING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S ASK FOR
OPENNESS AND AT A PUBLIC FACING
ON AND WE'RE WORKING ON THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO ENSURE
THAT THAT IS PUBLIC FACING FOR
YOU -- THE OTHER USES OF STATE
SET ASIDES OR TO SUPPORT NEW
CURRICULUM AND JUST ACCESS HOW
DO WE BUILD PROGRAMS QUICKLY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF EMPLOYERS.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU -- BUT I DO HAVE A ABOUT A
QUESTION THAT WAS ON IN THE
AGENDA AND ALSO ON THIS CHART.
YEAH I KNOW EARLY IN THE STRONG
WORK FORCE.
ROLL OUT THE AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE EFFECTIVENESS.
NO REPORTS -- COMING. ONE THING
THAT KIND OF YOU KNOW.
IS AYE POPPING IS HOW MUCH IS
SPENT ON YOUR CAPITAL THE AND
SALARIES ROUGHLY 50% AND HOW
MUCH IS GOING [inaudible]
TO NON.
CORE ISSUES THAT SAYS ADMIN SO
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE THAT IS
SUCH A TOP PRIORITY.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT MONEY IS GOING
OUT TO ACTUALLY PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS AND LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
REALLY TOP HEAVY.
I THINK ONE OF THE CHRISTMAS
MONEY WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE SITTING ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT -- WHEN THE PROGRAM WAS
CREATED -- WAS NOTED AS HIGH A
QUICKENING COSTS FOR CERTAIN C.
T. PROGRAMS THE ABILITY -- IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
CERTAIN PROGRAMS WE NEED -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE INVESTING
IN THE HIGH COST OF FACILITIES
IN HIGH CONSEQUENCE SO I THINK
YOU SEE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
BEING SPENT ON THAT I WOULD SAY --
THE 26% -- DEAN ROBERTS CAN HELP
ME OUT YOU KNOW IT I WOULD NOT.
I THINK WE WOULD DISAGREE WITH
THE CHARACTERIZATION THAT THAT'S
ALL ADMIN THAT FOR SOME OF THIS
WORK YOU KNOW I THINK.
A KEY PROBLEM STATEMENT OF OF A
STRONG WORK FORCE A REPORT WAS
THAT -- OUR COLLEGES NEED TO DO
A BETTER JOB OF LINKING UP WITH
THE WORK FORCE LINKING UP WITH
OTHER PRO OP PROGRAM PROVIDERS --
I WOULD ARGUE THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF WHAT WE ARE
FUNDING IN THAT -- IN THAT BLUE
CHUNK IN YOUR AGENDA RICK --
AROUND OTHER SERVICES AND COSTS.
BUT I GUESS TWO THINGS ONE YOU
SAY EQUIPMENT BUT EQUIPMENT IS
WELL I'M COUNTING THAT AS A AS
AN APPROPRIATE SOMETHING AND NON
EQUIPMENT AND NON INSTRUCTIONAL.
SALARY SO.
WILL THIS CHANGE OVER TIME
BECAUSE IT DOES LOOK LIKE YOU'RE
NOT FOCUSING THE CORE OF WHAT
MATTERS THE MOST WHICH IS WE
DEFINITELY WILL SEE A SHIFT.
LIKE -- VICE-CHANCELLOR'S MEN A
MENTION THE FIRST YEAR ROLLOUT
IT'S ABOUT SECURING THE SPACE IN
SECURING THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING TO DO THE WORK.
WE KNOW FULL WELL THAT OUR
FACULTY OR THE ONES THAT YOU
KNOW OR THAT POINT WHERE THE
CONTACT IS WITH STUDENTS AND SO.
NATURALLY WHEN WE SEE EXPANSION
OF OUR PROGRAMS GOING TO SEE
EXPANSION OF SOME FACULTY --
THESE ARE THESE ARE ALSO
POSITIONS THAT ARE SUCH LIKE
PLACEMENT OFFICERS -- SO THEIR
JOB PLACEMENT AGENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN HIRED INTO THE INTO THE
COLLEGES.
SO WHAT THE COLLEGES REALIZES
THAT WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB --
GOING FROM CONTINUING TO
CONTINUE ON AND SO THE THE LIFT
IN AND IN SALARIES WOULD BE TO
SORT OF HELP WITH THAT THOSE
THOSE CONNECTIONS SO -- BUT WE
DON'T FOR SEE THAT THOSE
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE WE WANT
TO SEE MORE NON CREDIT TO CREDIT
WE WANT TO SEE MORE CONTRACT AT
THE NON CREDIT TO CREDIT WE WANT
TO SEE MORE INVOLVEMENT UP ALL
OF THE PROGRAMS OUT THERE --
SOMEWHERE MESSAGING THIS TO THE
FIELD AS WELL.
BLESS WHATEVER I'VE JUST SAY
THAT -- I THINK PART OF THIS IS
DUE TO THE NEWNESS THAT A LOT OF
COLLEGES -- IN I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE TO USE
THESE DOLLARS -- FOR
PARTICULARLY COMPENSATION FOR
FACULTY GIVE AND NOT THINK THERE
IN GENERAL TENDS TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HOW STABLE AND HOW
SECURE CATEGORICAL PROGRAM
DOLLARS ARE AND WHETHER IT MAKES
SENSE FOR COLLEGES TO INVEST IN
THAT KIND OF COSTS.
I THINK AS THIS PROGRAM
CONTINUES -- HAVING SHOULD THERE
BE STABILITY I THINK YOU'LL SEE
MORE OF THOSE DOLLARS GOING INTO.
THOSE TYPES OF LONG TERM
COMMITMENTS.
OKAY.
MR O'DONNELL AT THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- SO THE PROGRAM
STARTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN IF
THAT'S CORRECT CORRECT IN THERE
BUT THERE IS REALLY REALLY BEEN
A SLIGHT INCREASE IN ENROLLMENT.
IS THAT ACCURATE [inaudible]
FTS.
YEAH THE F. T. S. RATES ARE THAT
WAS THE INCREASE -- THAT USE
THAT YOU SAW ON THE IN THE CHART
RIGHT -- THE COLLEGE IS COMING
OUT OF THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
YOU'RE GONNA SEE A LEVELING OFF
OF SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
ENROLLMENT ACROSS THE STATE AND
AND I DO UNDERSTAND IN BOTH
SYSTEMS K. TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT THERE'S AN OVERALL
DECLINE IN ROMANS WERE.
REDRESSING THAT AS WELL THAT'S
PART OF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING YES I
JUST I I THINK JUST.
TO EMPHASIZE THAT POINT THAT --
YOU KNOW I THINK YOUR OF YOUR
ENROLLMENT IS HAPPENING AT A
TIME WHEN -- OVERALL SYSTEM
ROMAN IS -- IS STABLE AND IN
MANY COMMUNITIES DECLINING SO I
TAKE LINING UP.
WHAT'S THAT YEAH THE CLINIC AND
SO I THINK THAT'S PART OF IT I I
WOULD JUST SAY THE OTHER YOU
KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE GOALS
WAS CAPACITY.
ANOTHER GOAL HAS BEEN IMPROVING
THE QUALITY OF C. T. E. I THINK
THE MEASURES ARE MEASURES AROUND
EARNINGS AFTER A PROGRAM.
ARE IMPORTANT WAY IN WHICH WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ARE WE
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF CG THAT
THE BUT SYSTEMS OFFERED TO
BASICALLY BACK TO THE ENROLLMENT
ISSUE.
BASE OF THE ARGUMENT OVER ALMOST
DROP AT CT ENROLLMENT IS UP
SLIGHTLY AS THAT YEAH THE GROWTH
FACTOR YET BY EIGHT BY PUSHING
THESE DOLLARS THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE
INCREASING THE ENROLLMENT OR THE
OR THE NUMBER STUDENTS THAT ARE
ATTENDING C. T. PROGRAMS.
SPECIFICALLY SAME THING GOES
WITH FACILITIES TO THOSE
FACILITIES BENEFITS HE TV
PROGRAMS AND WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
A THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING FOR
COLLEGES AND IN INTO TWO CAMPS
CAN CAN THE STRONG WORK FORCE
DOLLARS BE USED FOR SALARIES.
YES THEY CAN WHAT WE DO THERE IS
THERE'S THERE'S RECOMMEND ONE
YEAR HOW DOES THAT WORK BECAUSE
OF THE PROGRAMS ON GOING.
IT'S WE RECOMMEND TO COLLEGES
THAT BASED ON BEST PRACTICES
THAT THEY BECAUSE THIS IS A
CATEGORICAL.
THAT THEY SINK AND MULTIPLE
SOURCES TO TO SORT OF FUN THESE
POSITIONS -- ANOTHER WORDS.
NO MORE THAN 75% COMES OUT OF
ONE FUND RIGHT INTO FINDING A
POSITION SO THAT THEIR BRAIDING
FUNDS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
POSITION STAYS AROUND AS AS IT
GOES FORWARD.
SO I TYPES OF FLUCTUATIONS TO
THE TO THE DOLLARS TO HELP ME
UNDERSTAND HOW LONG IS A
REMAINING CATEGORICAL WHY WOULD
IT REMAIN ACCOUNTING OR WHY
WOULD TO BE.
BUILT INTO PART OF YOUR REGULAR
AN INSTRUCTIONAL FUNDING AT SOME
POINT WHEN IS IT FLIP.
YEAH NO SO FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE I I THINK BY
CATEGORICAL WE ARE JUST SAYING
FROM THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE
THIS FALLS OUTSIDE OF OUR
GENERAL PURPOSE OF FUNDING TO BE
ALLOCATED THE COLLEGES.
I THINK ON A WIDER.
WELL THAT'S A NEW INCENTIVIZE
YOU TO DO IT I'M I'M I'M I'M I'M
LOOKING OF THE K. TWELVE MODEL
MONEY WISE AND THAT SAME THING
HERE.
I THINK THAT INSTEAD OF EYES IT
GIVE YOU THE COUNTY.
IT WAS FUNNY SOMEONE SAID THE
CHAIR NOTED CAPITAL OUTLAY WAS
31% ACTUALLY AS TOO LOW.
SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
YES THE END AND BY CATEGORICAL
MAYBE I'LL JUST SAY WE THE STATE
HAS RESTRICTED THIS TWO HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT MILLION FOUR PER BY
KIND OF STRONG WORKFORCE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PURPOSES.
DISTRICTS ON THE MONEY WE
ALLOCATE PART OF THE MONEY MOST
OF THE MONEY TO DISTRICTS SOME
OF THE MONEY TO REGIONS AND THE
REGION'S EVENTUALLY ALLOCATED TO
DISTRICTS.
WHEN IT GETS TO THE DISTRICT ARE
HOPING I THINK CHANCELLOR OAKLEY
HAS MENTIONED TO THE FIELD
MENTIONED HERE BEFORE OUR HOPE
IS THAT DISTRICTS ARE TAKING ALL
THE DOLLARS THEY'RE GETTING?
USING THEM TOWARDS A COORDINATED
PROGRAM I THINK THAT CONCERNED --
OFTEN AT A DISTRICT LEVELS
AROUND THE RESTRICTIONS OF
FUNDING THE MAIN CONCERNS ABOUT
WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE -- TO
INKER LONG TERM OBLIGATIONS WITH
A DOLLARS LIKE THESE -- WHAT
THEIR EXPERIENCE HISTORICALLY
HAS BEEN USE DOLLARS CAN BE BOB
THESE TYPES OF DOLLARS SET ASIDE --
APPROPRIATIONS IN THE BUDGET CAN
BE -- MORE VOLATILE LESS SECURE
THAN OTHER TYPES OF FUNDING
GREAT THANK YOU NOTE TO MAKE TWO
COMMENTS -- IN I DO WORRY ABOUT
THE CONSORTIUM ON ALL.
THE STUFF CENTERS THE CONSORTIUM
THIS.
YOU KNOW THE SOVIET BLOCKING
GETS LOST AND THEN THERE'S YOU
KNOW TOO MUCH BUREAUCRATIC --
ACTIVITY REQUIREMENTS PAPERWORK
DECISIONS YOU MADE THEIR
POLITICAL DECISIONS INHERENTLY
IF YOU'RE IN A CONSORTIUM
COARSER BUT IT'LL YOU CAN'T TELL
ME THEY'RE NOT.
RIGHT THERE IS GOING TO ADVOCATE
FOR THEIR OWN THEIR OWN BECAUSE
SO THAT'S JUST ONE CONCERN I ALL
I ALSO HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
SYSTEM COLLEGE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE
IS LOOKING AT BREAKING DOWN --
THE BARRIERS WITH REGARD.
TO THE TIME ASSOCIATED TO
ACHIEVE A CERTIFICATE OR NAME
WHEN I MEAN BY THAT I MEAN THE
CAREER IN A YEAR APPROACH.
RIGHT DOWN THE SEMESTER THINKING.
SO THAT WE JUST KEEP GOING
THROUGH BECAUSE I MEAN THERE'S A
LOT THERE ARE SOME EVEN PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS OTHER THAN OVER
PRETTY GOOD PRODUCT THAT DO IT
IN A MUCH.
QUICKER FASHION ALBEIT MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE BUT IN A MUCH MORE
RAPID FASHION GETS YOU KNOW
THEIR STUDENTS INTO THE WORK
FORCE.
BUT I WOULD JUST SAY I THINK YOU
KNOW STRONG WORKFORCE LIVES
ALONG WITH A VARIETY OF OTHER
YOU KNOW EFFORTS THAT YOU KNOW
GUIDED PAHWAYS IS OUR WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO YOU MAKE
SURE.
STUDENT COMES INTO THE
INSTITUTION WITH AN EDUCATIONAL
GOAL WE GET THAT STUDENT TO THAT
GOAL -- IN THE MOST EFFICIENT
WAY POSSIBLE -- YOU KNOW I THINK
WE ARE SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
THINKING ABOUT APPRENTICESHIP
OTHER TYPES OF WORK BASED
LEARNING -- CREDIT FOR PRIOR
LEARNING SO THERE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER WORK THAT
THIS -- HOPEFULLY WILL BECOME
MORE ALIGNED WITH MOVING FORWARD.
AND JUST ONE MORE QUESTION A
QUESTION WITH THE NEW -- FOR
FUNDING FORMULA IT'S NOT GOING
TO DISSUADE -- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FROM SERVING THE STUDENTS WHO
DON'T WANT TO GET.
A NA OR DON'T WANT TO TRANSFER.
TO A TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY
CORRECT THAT'S NOT THE INTENT
THE GOAL OF IN THE FUNDING
FORMULA THERE ARE MEASURES THAT
ARE SPECIFICALLY AIMED AT TRYING
TO TARGET THIS STUDENT CHURNING
IS HOW WE'VE KIND OF TALKED
ABOUT IT -- COMPLETION OF NINE
OR MORE CT FACT CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION UNITS ATTAINMENT OF
REGIONAL LIVING WAGE UPON AG
SAID I THINK MOVING FORWARD WE
NEED TO EVALUATE THAT TO
COLLEGES FEEL LIKE THERE'S SOME
INCENTIVE TO PRIORITIZE CERTAIN
STUDENTS OVER OTHERS.
AND IF WERE SAYING THAT I THINK
THAT -- YOU KNOW IS -- GOING TO
INFORM OUR CONVERSATIONS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OFFER TRICKS
TO THE FORMULA.
THANK YOU.
SAY NO OTHER QUESTIONS WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN ISSUE NUMBER
THREE K. TWELVE CT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
HEY MICHELLE
.
ALL RIGHT.
MORNING.
AGAIN LA OF FIRST AND FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF ED CAN COLLEGES.
GOOD MORNING RYAN ANDERSON
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
CAN BE PRESENTING FROM A HANDOUT
THAT THE SERGEANTS JUST
PREPARING TO HAVE.
REAL QUICK.
IT'S A PRETTY HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW.
I'D STARTING OUT WITH A REMINDER
THAT -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS ORGANIZED THE STATE
WORKFORCE INTO -- FIFTEEN
INDUSTRY SECTORS AND FOR EACH OF
THESE INDUSTRY SECTORS THEY'VE
DEVELOPED SPECIFIC CURRICULUM
GUIDELINES FOR C. T. PROGRAMS.
THE SECOND PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
WE TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
OBJECTIVES OF THESE PROGRAMS
SURE MANY OF YOU OF VISITED CT
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE OF LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOLS AND MUCH OF WHAT
THEY DO THERE LOOKS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM -- TYPICAL HIGH
SCHOOL CURRICULUM BUT MANY WAYS
THE GOALS ARE PRETTY COURTS TO
THE MISSION OF K. TWELVE
EDUCATION THEY AND COULD
PROMOTING STERN ENGAGEMENTS TURN
STUDENTS FROM MORE ENGAGED WHEN
THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING HANDS ON
A TEACHING TECHNICAL SKILLS OF
COURSE.
TO INCREASE EMPLOYEE ABILITY
AMONG THOSE STRANDS BUT ALSO
TEACHING SOFT SKILLS JUST LIKE.
SHOWING UP TO WORK ON TIME.
IN ADDITION TO THAT -- CT
PROGRAMS ARE INTENDED TO HELP
THE STATE MADE ITS PARTICULAR
WORK FOR SCHOOLS.
NOW HISTORICALLY IN THIS THE
THIRD PAGE OF THE HANDOUT.
THE STATE HAS SUPPORTED HIGH
SCHOOL CT PROGRAMS PRIMARILY
THROUGH A COMBINATION OF
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS.
I'M PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WHICH IS TO
SAY PRIOR TO THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
IS A VARIETY OF SMALLER PROGRAMS
THE LARGEST OF WHICH WAS CALLED.
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS
AND PROGRAMS.
MANY OF THESE WERE ELIMINATED
WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF LCF F.
AND FROM 200-013-1422.
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CT
WAS -- SUPPORTED PRIMARILY
THROUGH A COMBINATION OF FUNDING
PROVIDED THROUGH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA THEY'LL
CFF.
INCLUDED A HIGHER HIGH SCHOOL A
BASE RATE THAN WAS PROVIDED FOR
OTHER GREATS IN PART TO
RECOGNIZE THE COST OF CITY
PROGRAMS.
AND THROUGH SOME LIMITED TERM
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS AND
SPECIFICALLY.
A PROGRAM CALLED THE CITY IN AN
INCENTIVE GRANT THIS WAS.
A PROGRAM THAT WAS DESIGNED TO
LAST FOR THREE YEARS PROVIDED --
DECREASING AMOUNT OF STATE
SUPPORT AND AN INCREASING LOCAL
MATCH.
ODD BUT BY THE TIME THAT WE CAME
AROUND -- TO THE AND THE PLANNED
EXPIRY OF THIS PROGRAM UGH THERE
WAS A GREAT INTEREST AMONG BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT CITY THROUGH A
CATEGORICAL APPROACH.
AND WHAT WE ENDED UP DOING IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WAS ACTUALLY
CREATE TWO SEPARATE.
ONGOING PROGRAMS BOTH.
OF RECEIVING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ANNUALLY THE FIRST OF
THESE WAS A CONTINUATION OF THE
SEATING INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM.
MRS IT MINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SUPPORTED SO HIGH SCHOOL IS ON A
COMPETITIVE BASIS -- IT HAS A
TWO TO ONE LOCAL MATCHING.
OF REQUIREMENTS SO SCHOOLS ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO DOLLARS OTHER LC
A FAT FOR OTHER FUNDS SOURCES
FOR EVERY.
DOLLAR EARNED DEDICATED FUNDING
THEY RECEIVED FOR THIS PROGRAM.
ON THE SECOND PROGRAM WAS A HIGH
SCHOOL A COMPONENT OF THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM THAT WE JUST
HEARD ABOUT SO.
THIS WORKS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
EXISTING STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM IT'S ADMINISTERED BY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
UGH THE FUNDING IS PROVIDED TO
THE REGIONAL CONSORTIA BASED ON
A FORMULA AS WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER.
AND THEN THE CONSORTIA AWARD
THOSE ON A COMPETITIVE BASIS TO
SCHOOLS IN THEIR AREA.
AGAIN THIS IS A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ON GOING AND IT'S A TWO
TO ONE LOCAL MATCH.
NOW.
A IN ADDITION TO THIS
CATEGORICAL FUNDING THIS IS ON
PAGE FOR THE HAND -- OF WE ARE
SUPPORTING CT THROUGH AT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THAT WAS
INTRODUCED ALONG WITH L. CFF.
SO ALL DISTRICTS UNDER LCF
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP STRATEGIC
PLANS THAT OUTLINE HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MEET.
US WIDE RANGE OF OBJECTIVES FOR
STUDENT OUTCOMES AMONG THOSE IS
PREPARING STUDENTS -- FOR BOTH
COLLEGE AND THEIR CAREER.
DODD TO ENSURE THAT THOSE PLANS
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY OUR SUCCESSFUL OF WE
ALSO INTRODUCED.
THIS SCHOOL DASHBOARD WHICH
SHOWS SOME.
INDICATOR DATA -- REVEALING HOW
SUCCESSFUL SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN IN
ACHIEVING THOSE OUTCOMES AMONG
THOSE INDICATORS IS THE COLLEGE
AND CAREER READINESS INDICATOR
THAT'S OUTLINED A AND THE LAST
PAGE OF THE HANDOUT PAGE.
FIVE THE IMPORTANT TAKE AWAY
HERE IS THAT -- IT STUDENTS CAN
QUALIFY AS PREPARED UNDER THE
INDICATOR -- IN PART BY
COMPLETING SOME CT COURSE WORK.
OUT THEM LATEST DATA WE HAVE
FROM THE INDICATOR -- SUGGEST
THAT WE STILL SOME WORK TO DO A
ABOUT 40% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
CURRENTLY.
CLASSIFIED AS PREPARED IN AND IT
DIGITAL 20% IS APPROACHING
PREPARED BUT THAT STILL LEAVES
40% LABELED AS NOT PREPARED.
THAT'S THE END OF MY
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS LENA GRANT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
REITERATING THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
BRINGING TOTAL LCF OF FUNDING TO
SIXTY THREE BILLION.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY IN
ADDITION AN AMOUNT EQUAL TO TWO
POINT 6% OF THE LC FF BASE GRANT
IS PROVIDED THROUGH THE NINE
THROUGH TWELVE GREAT SENATE JUST
MEANT. TO ACCOUNT FOR THE HIGHER
COST OF PROVIDING CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS AT
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL.
THIS BAY GRANT BASED GRANT
ADJUSTMENT AMOUNTS TO
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
BUILT AND ON TOP OF THE ELSE YET
THAT SPACE.
UGH BASE AMOUNT THE CAN BE USED
TO SUPPORT ROBUST CT PROGRAMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE LOCAL PRIORITY.
FUNDING ALLOCATED THROUGH THE LC
FF SHOULD PAY FOR A FULL RANGE
OF EDUCATIONAL COSTS INCLUDING
CT.
NESTED BY THE ELEVATOR LA -- IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
HIGH QUALITY SEE TV PROGRAMS
PLAY A VALUABLE ROLE IN
PREPARING STUDENTS TO MEET THE
STATE THE STATE'S LABOR MARKET
DEMANDS.
THE BUDGET MAINTAINS THE ONGOING
INVESTMENT THAT WERE NEGOTIATED
AS PART OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET. FOR BOTH CITY INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE KIDS WERE%
TWELVE COMPONENT OF THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AN ONGOING PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING IS PROVIDED
FOR THE LOCAL GRANTS.
TO KATE K. THROUGH TWELVE
ENTITIES UNDER EACH PROGRAM.
AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS AN ON GOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING IS PROVIDED
TO SUPPORT A REGIONAL LEADERSHIP
STRUCTURE TO ASSIST TEACHERS AND
INDUSTRY PARTNERS IN
IMPLEMENTING HIGH QUALITY C. T.
PROGRAMS.
AS WELL AS TWO MILLION DOLLARS
PROVIDED TO SUPPORT REGIONAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADMINISTERING THE TWELVE K.
THROUGH TWELVE COMPONENT OF THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
THESE PROGRAMS ALONG WITH THE
FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE LC A
FAST HELP TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN EFFECTIVE.
HIGH QUALITY CITY PROGRAMS THAT
ARE A LINE NOT ONLY THE WITH
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
STANDARDS.
BUT ALSO WITH THE NEEDS OF
EMPLOYERS INDUSTRY AND LABOR --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT MAKES SEVERAL TECHNICAL
CHANGES. TO THE LANGUAGE
GOVERNING BOTH PROGRAMS AS
STATED IN THE AGENDA.
THESE CHANGES ARE PROPOSED IN
RESPONSE TO RECOMMENDATIONS MADE
BY THE CALIFORNIA WORK FORCE
PATHWAYS JOINT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND AS WELL US
FEEDBACK RECEIVED FROM STICKLE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
FINALLY AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
CENTER.
SO CAL ROCK A SO CAL ROCKS
ADMITTED THERE REVISED
OPERATIONAL PLAN TO FINANCE ON
MARCH EIGHTEENTH.
AND WE WILL BE CONSIDERING THIS
ISSUE AS PART OF A MAJOR
REVISION.
I HAVE WITH ME AMBER ALEXANDER
ALSO FROM FINANCE ANDWE'RE
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING BUDGETARY MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS I'M CHAU MACINTOSH
ADMINISTRATOR OF THE CITY
LEADERSHIP OFFICE TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND.
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT OF C. TAKE
AND PROVIDING FUNDING INTO
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANT SEATED.
UNDERSEA TAKE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE AN EXPANSIVE T.
PROGRAMS DRIVEN BY STUDENT
INTEREST CURRENT REGIONAL AND
STATEWIDE LABOR MARKET DATA.
INDUSTRY ADVOCACY AND
INVOLVEMENT AND ALIGNMENT WITH
PROGRAMS OFFERED AT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
K. TWELVE CT IS UNIQUE FROM CITY
PROGRAMS OFFERED IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THAT THEY EMPHASIZE
THE INTEGRATION OF GENERAL
EDUCATION ACADEMICS.
WITH CTE COURSES ARE BASED ON
THE CT MODEL CURRICULUM
STANDARDS.
CAREER TECHNICAL STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND STUDENT
LEADERSHIP ARE INTEGRAL TO CT
COURSE OBJECTIVES AND STUDENTS
ARE PROVIDED WITH THE CONTINUE A
WORK BASED LEARNING EXPERIENCES.
THEY'RE OUT THERE SEE TV COURSE
SEQUENCE.
HERE'S A QUICK UPDATE ON THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SEE
TAKE APPLICATION PROCESS.
APPLICATIONS OPEN TO LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ON DECEMBER
NINETEENTH THE DEADLINE FOR
THOSE WAS JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE
RECEIVED THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE TOTAL APPLICATIONS
OF WHICH THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO APPLICATIONS WERE READ AND
SCORED. THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN SERVICE AB APPLICATIONS
WERE FUNDED AND THEY SERVE A
REPRESENTATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES.
WITH THE PRELIMINARY ALLOCATION
OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS -- WE ALLOCATED THE
FUNDS AND WE HAVE OUR GRANT
AWARD NOTIFICATIONS -- THAT ARE
READY TO GO OUT OF OUR OFFICE IN
BE DELIVERED TO THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES WITHIN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS.
THE REGARDING THE DETAILS OF ALL
THIS AND THE FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN I'M
GRANT WAS OPEN MADE AVAILABLE ON
THE NINETEENTH OF DECEMBER.
THE GRANT APPLICATION ITSELF
INCLUDED A TWO PART PROCESS ONE
AN ONLINE SUBMISSION OF GENERAL
LOCAL AGENCY INFORMATION.
WITH THE AMOUNT OF THE LA DA --
WOULD BE ABLE TO MATCH AND
SECOND A PAPER COPY SUBMISSION.
INCLUDING AS SELF EVALUATION OF
THE LA GAZE HIGH QUALITY SEE TV
PROGRAMS.
A SIX PAGE NARRATIVE REFLECTING
ON THE HIGH QUALITY C. T.
EVALUATION.
A ONE YEAR BUDGET.
AND TO SHOW THE AND THEN A THREE
YEAR BUDGET TO SHOW ON GOING
SUPPORT FOR THE PROGRAM.
APPLICATIONS WITHIN DUE ON
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH THE NIGHT
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WAS A VERY
TIGHT TURN AROUND. FOR DISTRICTS
HOWEVER WE WANTED TO GET THE
APPLICATION PROCESS DONE -- AND
ALSO PROVIDE PRELIMINARY
ALLOCATIONS PRIOR TO THE MARCH
FIFTEENTH NOTICING AND I HAD THE
FIELD.
OVERALL THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION RECEIVED
A TOTAL OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE GRANT APPLICATIONS.
OF THESE APPLICATIONS TO DID NOT
COMPLETE PART ONE OF THE
APPLICATIONS. THIRTY THREE DID
NOT COMPLETE PART TO THE
APPLICATION AND THEN T.
APPLICATIONS WORST RECEIVED A
LATE. FOR THIS PARTICULAR ROUND
OF FUNDING A TOTAL OF SEVENTY
SEVEN PREVIOUS APPLICANTS DID
NOT APPLY -- HOWEVER WE HAD
FORTY FOUR NEW APPLICANTS THAT
APPLIED FOR THIS ROUND. FOR THE
SCORING PROCESS THE CUT SCORE TO
BE FUNDED WITH THIRTY FOUR
POINTS AND SCORES RANGE FROM ONE
TO NINETY FOUR POINTS OUT OF A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED IN TOTAL
THREE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
APPLICATIONS WERE READ AND
SCORED -- OF THESE APPLICATIONS
THREE APPLICATIONS DID NOT MEET
THE MINIMUM CUT SCORE ONE
APPLICATION DID NOT INCLUDE A
NARRATIVE ONE APPLICATION DID
NOT INCLUDE THE SELF EVALUATION
OR THE THREE YEAR PLAN -- AGAIN
THE APPLICATION ITSELF WAS WORTH
A TOTAL OF ONE HUNDRED ONE
HUNDRED POINTS. NINETY POINTS
FOR THE SELF EVALUATION TWO
POINTS FOR THE NARRATIVE TWO
POINTS FOR THE ONE YEAR BUDGET
AND THEN SIX POINTS FOR THE
THREE YEAR BUDGET.
THE FUNDING RESULTS OF THE TOTAL
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
APPLICATIONS WILL BE FUNDED
SERVING FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO ELEAZAR THE LIST OF THE
GRANTEES WAS PROVIDED -- ALSO
THIS INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT INDIVIDUAL LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES AND THEN THIRTY NINE
CONSORTIUM MADE UP OF TWO OR
MORE -- AND WHICH REPRESENT A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES --
OF THAT FIFTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE REPRESENTED AND A
HAND THAT WAS PROVIDED TO YOU
THAT SHOWS THE SPREAD OF THE
DOLLARS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO IN EACH AND IT'LL SHOW BY
COUNTY SEVENTY TWO COUNTY CAN
SEE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF GRANTS
THAT WERE AWARDED AND THEN THE
TOTAL DOLLARS THAT WERE WORDED
TO THAT COUNTY.
SINCE SOME OF THE POSITIVE --
LED PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION --
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS YEAR AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE WRITTEN IN THE GRANTS
TO BE COMPLETED THIS YEAR --
INCLUDE INCLUDE THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF ABC UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL WRITE A
LETTER TO EACH STUDENT WHO
COMPLETES THEIR EDUCATION
PATHWAY GUARANTEEING THEM AN
INTERVIEW FOR DISTRICT TEACHING
POSITION.
WHEN THEY GRADUATE FROM POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION -- RED BLUFF
HIGH SCHOOL OFFER SIXTY NINE
SECTIONS OF CTE COURSES WITHIN
ELEVEN OF THE FIFTEEN INDUSTRY
SECTORS.
ON THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
ACTUALLY VOTED TO EXPAND THE
TRADITIONAL SIX PERIOD DAY TO
SEVEN PERIOD DAY.
SO THAT ALL STUDENTS COULD
COMPLETE A TWO YEAR SEQUENCE OF
COURSES IN A CITY PATHWAYS A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT.
AND THIS YEAR THE CLASS OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE THE
FIRST CLASS TO HAVE ALL
GRADUATES COMPLETING A SEQUENCE
OF COURSES IN THE CT BAFFLED.
IN THE CITY PATHWAYS.
A CONTRA COSTA CDO EAT AT COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION REPORTED
NEARLY 80% 86% OF THEIR TEACHERS.
REPORT THAT THEIR STUDENTS
PARTICIPATE AND WORK BASED
LEARNING WILL CONTINUE THOUGH
BECAUSE CONTINUE TO BE ACTIVE
PARTNERS IN THE EARNED LEARNING
SPANISH SHOULD HAVE WITH THE
GOAL OF EXPANDING INDUSTRY
PARTNERSHIPS AND WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
STUDENTS.
AND IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
CONSORTIUM MEMBERS WILL SAYS
THEIR PRACTICES FOR COLLECTING
DATA PERTAINING TO WORK BASED
LEARNING.
AND LOOK AT HOW BEST TO CAPTURE
THIS DATA AND ELEMENT OF C. T..
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR PIECE
COMMUNITY CLASSROOM METHODOLOGY
WE OFFER TO CONSORTIUM MEMBERS
THE CONSORTIUM WILL ALSO
LEVERAGE THE WORK OF THE INLAND
DESERT REGIONAL STRONG WORK
FORCE CONSORTIUM. TO LEARN ABOUT
THE LAUNCH OF FRIENDSHIP NETWORK
PROJECT WHICH IS A YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP COMPONENT TO IT.
AND AS PART OF EXPANDING THE
ROLE OF RECOGNIZED
APPRENTICESHIPS.
I'M ALSO FOR OUR REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
AS FUNDING FOR SEVEN REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
COMES TO AN END IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE'D LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OP LIKE. TO NEED TO
PUBLICLY THANK THEM FOR THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK IN
SUPPORT THEY PROVIDED TO THE
FIELD.
DURING THE PAST THREE YEARS AND
PROVIDE YOU -- WITH SOME DATA ON
THE PERFORMANCE SO WITH THAT --
WE ALSO AT I ALSO PASSED OUT A
AT CAREER TECHNICAL IT'S AN OF
GRANT DATA SURVEY THIS IS THE
SNAPSHOT THAT SHOWS OUR FIRST
OUT COMES FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THIS PAST
YEAR DATA -- AND SO WHEN WE LOOK
AT THIS WE HAVE 87% OF GRANTEES
THAT RESPONDED -- AND WE'RE
STILL GETTING -- RESPONSES BACK
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY NEED TO
RESPOND TO THIS INFORMATION THIS
IS WHAT THEY AGREED TO GIVE US --
WE HAD 500-800-00800 AND THIRTY
STUDENTS PARTICIPATE.
I'M IN PROGRAM SUPPORTED BY SEE
TAKE FUNDS IN AS YOU CAN SEE --
BY BELOW SEA TAKE VERSES THE
STATE THAT 500-800-00800 AND
THIRTY STUDENTS AT REPRESENTS
OVER THE NINE A REPRESENTS -- A
GOOD PERCENTAGE OF THE TOTAL OF
900-810-00900 SIXTY SEVEN TOTAL
CTP ENROLLMENTS.
I'M SO THAT'S 59% -- WERE
TOUCHED BY THOSE CT INCENTIVE
GRANT DOLLARS.
I 1-007-100-0300 TWENTY FIVE CT
GRADUATES IN -- TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WITH HAVING
THESE FUNDS.
AND THEN -- WHAT'S REALLY AS
NICE TO SEE IS THAT
CERTIFICATION SO THIS WAS ONE OF
THE OUTCOMES REQUIRED IN
LEGISLATIONS START EARLY REPORTS
SHOW THAT 570-009-0050 FIVE
STUDENTS.
EARNED ACTUAL INDUSTRY
RECOGNIZED CERTIFICATIONS --
EXAMPLES CUP TIA AT AND DAMS
WHICH IS THE NATIONAL METAL
WORKING SKILLS -- MICROSOFT
OFFICE CPR AND FOOD SAFE IN
ADOBE FIVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE STUDENTS
EARNED CALIFORNIA LICENSES FOR
EXAMPLE REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANT AT MEDICAL ASSISTANT
AND THEN IN THE AREAS OF
COSMETOLOGY.
AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED FORTY STUDENTS
PARTICIPATED IN THIRD PARTY
ASSESSMENTS -- EXAMPLES OF THAT
WOULD BE KNOCKED DE IN PRECISION
EXAMS.
THANK YOU GIVE NEXT.
HELLO AGAIN MY NAME'S MATT
ROBERTS ON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CANCERS
OFFICE GOOD MORNING TO THE TO
THECOMMITTEE THIS MORNING.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ON K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE IN THIS FIRST
YEAR REALLY IT'S A PLEASURE TO
SIT AT THE TABLE WITH C. D. E.
AND AND HAVE SORT OF OUR
MARCHING ORDERS -- TO BUILD
SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY LINK BACK AND FORTH
WHEN I READ SOME OF THE GREAT
DATA THAT'S COMING OUT OF SOME
OF THE ELLIE ETS -- WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DATA SAID
SORT OF MOVES FORWARD IN TELLING
THE STORY HOW STUDENTS GO ON TO
COLLEGE AND CAREER.
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF GAINING.
THE TYPES OF WORK FORCE OUTCOMES
THAT WERE AFTER SO WE'VE BEEN
HAPPY TO THINK SIT DOWN WITH CD
AND WORK VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH
THEM -- ALSO THE THE CALIFORNIA
JOINT WORK FORCE ADVISORY BOARD
HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE.
PARTICIPANT IN NOT ONLY THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF PERKINS BUT
ALSO SORT OF THE SHEPHERDING OF
OUR METRICS AND BOTH SYSTEMS FOR
BOTH SEATED AGAIN THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE.
SO THAT'S BEEN A VALUABLE PIECE
IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT THE
POLICIES WRAPAROUND THE TYPES OF
ENGAGEMENT IN THE TYPES OF
CONNECTIONS THAT WERE AFTER SO --
SO WE IN THIS FIRST YEAR OF ROLL
OUT OF K. TWELVE STRONG WORK
FORCE WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE TIMELINE WAS SIMILAR TO WHAT
SEE TAKE ROLLED OUT -- TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WASN'T SORT
OF APPLICATION OVERLOAD FOR THE
FIELD BECAUSE THERE WERE TWO TWO
SEPARATE APPLICATIONS WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD NOW AND AS
APPLICATIONS OF COME IN AS OF
MARCH FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN FOR K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE.
WE'RE NOW LOOKING TO SEE WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE CONNECTION WAS C.
TAKE APPLICANTS VERSES
APPLICANTS FOR K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE.
HOW ARE THESE DOLLARS BEING USED
FOR THE DOLLARS BEING LEVERAGED
TOGETHER -- WHERE IS THE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA THAT SORT OF
THEIR -- THAT THEY'RE PLAYING
AND AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT IN
THE ROLL OUT OF THIS WE HAD TWO
GOALS ONE IS TO GIVE ALL ELEAZAR
ACCESS TO FUNDING -- AND NUMBER
TWO TO LET FOLKS KNOW WHAT THE
NEXT STEPS WERE TO APPLY FOR
DOLLARS SO MOST OF OUR SYSTEMS
FOR APPLYING -- ONLINE THROWN
OVER PROCESS -- WHICH WAS BEEN
VERY GOOD IN TERMS OF US BEING
ABLE TO COLLECT DATA.
AND I DO HAVE SOME APPLICATION
DATA FOR YOU THAT I'D LIKE TO
SHARE -- IN THIS FIRST ROUND WE
HAD A TOTAL OF EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE LETTERS OF IN
INTENSE OR LETTERS OF INTEREST
THAT WERE SUBMITTED FROM THE
FIELD.
AS A FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN OF THOSE.
OF THOSE LETTERS OF INTENT WE
RECEIVED FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT APPLICATIONS --
OVERALL ACROSS THE STATE.
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS THAT WE RECEIVED AS
ARE MOST MOST RURAL AREA AND
THAT'S FROM SACRAMENTO TO THE
OREGON BORDER WE RECEIVED A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
APPLICATIONS.
AS YOU KNOW MANY OF THE
DISTRICTS AND THE NORTH FOR
NORTH AREA OR BELOW TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY A OR STUDENT ENROLLMENT.
AND SO WE'RE REALLY REALLY.
PLEASE TO TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY GET THE APPLICATION
PROCESS IS WORKING WE'RE AFTER
INCENTIVIZING THE GROWTH OF OUR
CAREER EDUCATION PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY IN OUR RURAL AREAS.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR AREAS THAT ARE
HIT BY -- HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT YET
MIGHT NOT HAVE THE POPULATION --
ANOTHER AREA AS YOU GO DOWN AS I
GO DOWN THIS LIST THE BAY AREA
HAD SIXTY NINE APPLICATIONS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY MOTHER LODE
FROM STOCKTON -- DOWN TO
BAKERSFIELD AT SIXTY SIX SOUTH
CENTRAL COAST WHICH IS OUR
SMALLEST AT SEVEN SHOWS THE
LEVEL OF INTEGRATION WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE -- SAN DIEGO
IMPERIAL THIRTY TWO AND I HAVE
TO SAY.
A NUMBER OF THOSE APPLICATIONS
ARE COMING FROM IMPERIAL COUNTY.
THE FOLKS DOWN THERE ARE ARE
HUNGRY AND READY FOR THE TYPE OF
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PRESENT AROUND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
AND AROUND CREATION OF PROGRAMS
THAT REALLY MOVE STUDENTS INTO
JOBS -- THE INLAND EMPIRE DESERT
REGION HAD FORTY SEVEN THERE'S A
LOT OF PARITY BETWEEN THE NUMBER
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
THAT AREA.
A LOS ANGELES AT NINETY THREE A
LARGE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS.
PROBABLY THE SECOND HIGHEST
COMPARED TO THE MOST RURAL AREA.
AND THEN LASTLY ORANGE COUNTY
HAD.
SEVENTEEN THE TOTAL DOLLARS THAT
WERE REQUESTED WERE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION AND AS YOU
KNOW THE ALLOCATION AMOUNTS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
SO HERE AGAIN MUCH LIKE WHAT
MICHELLE PRESENTED FOR C. TECH --
THE NEED SEEMS TO BE OUT OUT
PACING WHAT THE DOLLAR SIR ARE
AVAILABLE ARE SO IT'S ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OVER WHAT
WHAT'S AVAILABLE.
UP WE'RE CURRENTLY RUNNING.
SELECTION COMMITTEES PER
LEGISLATION AND THE THESE THE
SELECTION COMMITTEES ARE ARE
WELL REPRESENTED OF AND AND A
VERY DIVERSE GROUP OF FOLKS
REPRESENTING.
ANYWHERE FROM OUR PEAS TO
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD FOLKS
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ELLIE
ACE -- AND SO THEY'RE
DELIBERATING ON WHO'S GOING TO
GET FUNDING.
AND WE'RE SPENDING A LOT OF
TIMES WITH THESE WITH THESE
FOLKS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOT OF
AUTHORITY OUT OF THE LEGISLATION.
TO ENSURE NOT ONLY THAT THE
DOLLARS FLOW TO PROGRAMS BUT
THAT WERE REALLY MAKING THESE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN HOW DO WE
SEQUENCE STUDENTS FROM SECONDARY
TO POST SECONDARY.
IF WE WERE TO MAKE A DENT IN THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE SEE THIS PROGRAM SORT OF
DELIVERING FOR US IS HOW DO WE
REALLY SHINE A LIGHT ON THAT ON
THAT PIECE.
OF THE APPLICATIONS ARE LIKE I
SAID ARE CURRENTLY BEING SCORED
THE FINAL DECISIONS WILL GO OUT
BY APRIL THIRTIETH.
AND DOLLARS WILL FLOW THIS YEAR
BEFORE JUNE JUNE FIFTEENTH SO WE
HAVE.
THINGS IN Q. TWO TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
THE OTHER PART OF THIS
LEGISLATION HAS TO DO WITH KEY
TALENT AND I KNOW MACHEL --
GRACIOUSLY THANKED.
THE SEATED TAPS WE HAVE SIMILAR
TAPS -- OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS THAT WE FUNDED THROUGH
SB TEN SEVENTY AND THAT HAVE
ENDED AS WELL.
SO THE INTENT WITH TRYING TO
WEAVE THESE POSITIONS SOMEWHAT
TOGETHER WAS TO TRY TO TAKE THE
ENDING DOLLARS FOR THESE
DISPARATE POSITIONS.
MERGE THEM TOGETHER SOMEWHAT AND
SEE IF THEY COULD REALLY PROVIDE
THAT PIPELINE IN THAT GUIDANCE
AND ASSISTANCE TO INSURE THAT
PROGRAMS MOVE FORWARD.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
THE EIGHT REGIONAL FOLKS.
THAT WERE CALLED OUT FOR IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT'S IN
MOTION WE'RE WE'RE CURRENTLY
FINISHING INTERVIEWS ON IT.
THE OTHER SEVENTY TWO BODIES OR
SORRY NOT BODIES BUT TALENT WILL.
WILL BE ROLLING OUT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS WE HAVE
EVERYTHING READY FOR THAT. TO GO
SO THESE BUT THESE FOLKS WILL BE
IN PLACE AT THE BEGINNING OF
NEXT YEAR -- TO ASSIST WITH --
BUT THE REGIONAL COORDINATION.
AND THEN ALSO THE APPLICATION
PROCESS I'LL HAVE TO TELL YOU
SOME OF THE VIGNETTES STATEMENTS
THAT I'VE HEARD AROUND THE STATE.
AND I I MADE SURE THAT I WAS THE
ONE THAT WENT OUT AND DID ENGAGE
BEEN ACROSS THE STATE WE DID
THESE ENGAGEMENT MEETINGS WITH
ALL EL THE ETS WE ENGAGE WITH
PROBABLY. TWELVE TO THIRTEEN
HUNDRED FOLKS STATEWIDE -- AND
AND THE THINGS THAT THAT FOLKS
ARE TALKING ABOUT IS HOW DO WE
INCREASE THE COLLABORATION.
THE SAME THING GOES WITH OUR
REGIONAL CONSORTIA IT'S HOW DO
WE ENGAGE THAT THAT THAT TYPE OF
A COLLABORATION TO MAKE IT WHAT
MILLBRAE MCLAUGHLIN CALLS.
VERY MEANINGFUL IT'S THAT
DELIBERATE COLLABORATION THAT
WERE AFTER SO WE'RE HAPPY IN
THIS FIRST YEAR THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SORT OF GET IT OUT OF
THE GATE WITH FIDELITY AS IT'S
WRITTEN -- AND WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
GOING FORWARD WE ARE LINING OUR
METRICS MORE WERE LINING WHERE
THAT INVESTMENT IS GOING TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS STUDENTS
MAKE IT SO.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE THIS MORNING
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
ALREADY THIS IS A INFORMATIONAL
ITEM FOR THE MISTER DONALD HAS
SOME COMMENTS TOO BUT AYE AYES
ONCE A WEEK WE ALL SUPPORT -- C.
T. E. -- WE WE WE LIKED THE THE
K. TWELVE MODEL AND APPRECIATE
YOUR PASSION BUT I THINK IT'S
OUR INTENT.
TO REDIRECT THE ONE FIFTY TO GO
BACK TO THE INITIAL -- SYSTEM
THAT WE SET OUT THAT I THINK
MISTER O'DONNELL IS PROPOSING.
IN SOME LEGISLATION IT WILL
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT THAT --
I'M NOT SURE GIVE ME JUST MORE
MONEY PER SE TO ADD ON TO IT
WE'RE READY FOR THE MAY REVISE
BUT I THINK THE DESIRE REST IS
TO GO BACK TO IT TO A SINGULAR
APPROACH THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
BE THE ACTION.
COMING OUT THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN
MAY.
THANK YOU MISTER DON.
YES YEAH JUST JUST TWO COMMENTS
GUARD QUICKLY MISTER CHAIR.
I THINK -- AS EVIDENCED BY YOUR
WHAT THE INFORMATION THE DATA
YOU'VE SHARED TODAY WE ARE NOT
FUNDING C. T. AN ADEQUATE LEVEL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THERE'S WHAT SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS -- WAS
WHAT PEOPLE SOUGHT YET THERE'S
ONLY THREE HUNDRED MILLION
AVAILABLE SO THAT WE ALL AGREE
THAT ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO FUND
C. T..
AND MORE ADEQUATE LEVELS BETTER
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND ALSO BETTER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY -- MY
SECOND COMMENT IS THAT -- I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM SHOULD NOT BE
ADMINISTERING K. TWELVE DOLLARS --
AND I THINK WE'RE SEEING SOME
EVIDENCE OF THAT NOW.
SPLITTING THE THE K. TWELVE IN
CT FUNDING INTO TWO PROGRAMS.
FROM WHAT I'M HEARING IT IS IT
HAS SOME CHALLENGES MAY NOT A ME
WORKING.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICES
IN TEACHERS SAY THE STRONG WORK
WORKS PROGRAM APPLICATIONS IS
APPLICATION PROCESS IS
BURDENSOME.
TAKES EIGHTY TO ONE HUNDRED
HOURS TO COMPLETE EACH
APPLICATION.
AND THEN THERE'S A SEPARATE
APPLICATION REQUIRED FOR EACH
PATHWAY.
SO -- SIGNIFICANTLY BURDENSOME
APPLICATION PROCESS WHO WERE
HEARD ABOUT.
AND THE METRICS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM ARE
GEARED TOWARD STUDENTS ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- STUDENTS.
GOING DIRECTLY INTO AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM ORDER FOR
UNIVERSITY WOULD NOT COUNT AS
SUCCESS.
SO THERE'S A CHALLENGE AND
ELEAZAR REPORTING THAT THERE IS
A LACK OF SUPPORT FROM THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CONSORTIUMS
AND APPLYING FOR FUNDS.
AND YOU KNOW I HAVE MY CONCERNS
ABOUT CONSORTIUM -- COMPETITION
WISE EXETER AND ALSO JUST JUST
MORE BUREAUCRACY WITH REGARD TO
PAPERWORK AND LOGISTICS -- AND
THEN THERE'S BEEN REPORTS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNWILLING TO
COLLABORATE.
UNLESS THE CAGE WALL PATHWAY
FEEDS INTO THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PATHWAYS I THINK THAT'S
AN ISSUE -- AND AGAIN I I I
THINK WE NEED TO RETURN.
THIS FUNDING -- THAT HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION MINISTER
IT AS THEY DO WITH C. TAKE NOW
PROPER PLACE -- WITH THAT I'VE
I'VE SAID MY PIECE MISTER CHAIR
I TURN IT BACK TO YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THING I WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPENED FOR THE MAY REVISION.
ISSUE NUMBER FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION
[inaudible]
HEY
.
WELL TAKE ROLL REAL QUICK
[inaudible]
THE REAL [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
RCG O'DONNELL.
OKAY THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS MICHELLE
A LEADER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND.
OF WHICH ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN MILLION AS ONE TIME FOR
EXPANDED SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
SCHOOL READINESS SUPPORTS KNOWN
AS THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
CONCENTRATION GRANT.
THIS FUNDING IS TARGETED AT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WITH
HIGH PERCENTAGES OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND HIGH RATES
OF AND DUPLICATED PUPILS SO
STUDENTS WHO ARE -- ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE AND YOUTH FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
THESE FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO
SUPPLEMENT SERVICES BEYOND WHAT
IS AN INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION
PROGRAM AS WELL AS FOR
PREVENTIVE SERVICES SUCH AS
EARLY INTERVENTION AND PRESCHOOL.
THE FUNDS CAN ALSO BE USED TO
ADOPT STRATEGIES TO IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IDENTIFIED TO THE
STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AS WELL
AS TO EXPAND OR BUILD UPON.
MULTI MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT EFFORTS ARE AND TSS.
BOTH THE ONGOING AND THE ONE
TIME FUNDS WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS PROPOSAL IS A HISTORIC
INVESTMENT IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
WITH A FOCUS ON EQUITY BUT IS
ALSO A STRATEGIC INVESTMENT.
BY TARGETING ADDITIONAL FUNDS
WERE THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES THIS PROPOSAL AIMSTO
IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE STUDENTS AND
HIGH NEED AREAS AND TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AT RISK OF ACQUIRING
RELATED SERVICES.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING RYAN AND HE'S LA UP.
RYAN ANDERSON ALEJO.
OF WE'RE RECOMMENDING THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON THIS
ISSUE AND ONE PRIMARY REASON WHY
IS THAT.
WE DON'T THINK THE DESIGN OF THE
PROGRAM IS LIKELY TO ACHIEVE THE
GOVERNOR STATED INTENT.
AS FINANCE JUST NOTED.
THEIR INTENT IS THAT THIS
FUNDING BE USED FOR EITHER
SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES THOSE
BEING SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY PROVIDED TO THOSE.
STUDENTS WERE FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION EFFORTS WHICH WOULD
BE -- EFFORTS OF SCREENING AND
CHILDREN FOR BEHAVIORAL OR
ACADEMIC CHALLENGES AND
PROVIDING THEM SOME SUPPORTS.
THAT WOULD DIVERT THEM FROM THE
NEED -- FOR BEING IDENTIFIED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
NOW THAT'S THEIR INTENT AND
THERE IS SOME ASSOCIATED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT LIST THESE
PURPOSES BUT THE LANGUAGE ITSELF
IS NOT CONTROLLING.
A BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH DISTRICTS WE THINK THAT THE
THE MESSAGE THEY WOULD RECEIVE
FROM THIS PROGRAM IS.
IS -- FROM ITS TITLE SPECIAL
EDUCATION CONCENTRATION GRANTS
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
SAYING THAT RISING SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS ARE ONE OF THEIR
PRIMARY -- FISCAL CONCERNS AT
THIS MOMENT -- THEY'RE ASKING
SPECIFICALLY FOR MORE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING TO COVER
THOSE EXISTING SERVICES AND WE
BELIEVE THAT ABSENT CONTROLLING --
SPENDING RESTRICTIONS THEY WILL
INTERPRET THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AS FUNDING FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
NAY IN ADDITION WE THINK THAT
THE ALLOCATION FORMULA THAT WAS
PROPOSED TO SPECIFICALLY
MISALIGNED WITH THE INTENT OF
REDUCING IDENTIFICATION.
OF STUDENTS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
SO FEW STUDENTS WOULD QUALIFY
FOR THE FUNDING UNDER THAT
STUDENTS ARE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- FOR EVERY STUDENT
THAT AND IDENTIFIED DISTRICT THE
CEASE TO IDENTIFY FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION WE ESTIMATE THEY'D
LOSE OUT ON OF APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ON
GOING FUNDING THAT.
THAT SEEMS TO BE AS STRONG
FISCAL INCENTIVE NOT TO REDUCE
YOUR IDENTIFICATION RIGHT.
NOW FINALLY IT BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT THIS FUNDING WOULD BE USED
TO SUPPORT.
EXISTING SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES WE DO NOT THAT.
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE AS
SUPERIOR OPTIONS FOR ALLOCATING
SPECIAL EDUCATION KALICH
CATEGORICAL FUNDING IN
PARTICULAR.
IN THE CURRENT FUNDING RATES ARE
PROVIDED UNDER THE STATE'S
PRIMARY SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING FORMULA.
ARE A QUITE UNEQUAL RANGING IN
SOME AREAS FROM LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER STUDENTS WHO.
AND SOME CASES MORE THAN NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER STUDENT
THESE -- INEQUITIES ARE BASED.
WHOLLY ON A HISTORICAL FACTORS
THEY HAVE NO RATIONAL POLICY
BASIS -- WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE.
A COULD DEDICATE SOME FUNDING TO
EQUALIZING THOSE RATES IN
ADDITION -- THERE IS THIS
DISCONNECT AS NOTED AND THE
AGENDA THAT SCHOOLS ARE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED OFFER SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES THERE FOR
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS BUT THE
STATE'S SYSTEM FOR ALLOCATING
FUNDING ISBASED ENTIRELY ON K.
THROUGH TWELVE ATTENDANCE WHICH
MEANS.
THERE'S NO FUNDING PROVIDED
SPECIFICALLY -- FOR THOSE
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WAIT WAIT
THINK AGAIN THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DEDICATE FUNDING SOME
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT
PURPOSE AND THAT WOULD BE
SUPERIOR TO THE GOVERNOR'S
ALTERNATIVE.
AT THAT'S ALL.
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN RIGHT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION -- ON
BEHALF OF THE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND --
THE SUPERINTENDENT IS SUPPORTIVE
AND APPRECIATES ALL ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ENSURING THAT OUR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES HEY
WE RECOGNIZE.
THAT OUR STATE'S HIGHEST NEED
YOUTH OFTEN REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORTS -- TO BE INCLUDED IN
SCHOOL -- INCREASED FUNDING FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION CONTINUES TO
BE AT THE TOP OF THE MINDS OF OF
AS THE ELIO -- ALSO SEE THE
SENTIMENT AT THAT -- FUNDING IS
A HUGE ISSUE AROUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION IN GENERAL SO ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDS -- WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED BOTH FOR
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES OF ONE OF
OUR MOST CHALLENGE SUBGROUPS.
OF THE SUPERINTENDENT ALSO
THRILLED TO HAVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- HAVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
AND WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE --
AND WE HOPE THAT AS WE CONTINUE
TO INVEST IN OUR TEACHERS BOTH
THE GENERAL AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS -- THEY ALSO
NEED SUPPORT AND MENTORSHIP SO
WE SEE THIS AS PART OF A PUZZLE.
THAT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT FUNDING
IT'S ABOUT SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS IN THE FUNDING P. SEEMS
TO BE ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
PIECES THAT'S PREVENTING US FROM
MOVING FORWARD WITH MANY OF THE
OTHER PIECES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER MEDINA --
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS -- BOTH OF THE ALEJO'S
OFFICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
I I I'M GONNA TO SHARE -- RATHER
THAN ASK QUESTIONS -- OWNER
SHARED THAT I HAVE AUTHORED
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH I THINK IT DOES SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT -- ALEJO'S
OFFICE AS ALLUDED.
TO AND AND THAT IS IT WOULD
PROVIDE.
SOME THE BILL FOR TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH I'VE AUTHORED UP PROVIDES
MUCH NEEDED FUNDING FOR THE
EQUALIZATION.
A SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
RATES FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL SERVICES.
WHICH THE LA -- SUGGESTED AND
FOR A HIGH COST OF PLACEMENTS.
I HEAR FROM MY OWN LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT THE WITH THE LA --
OFFICES SAID THAT THE FUNDING
SYSTEM IS A CERTAINLY OUR CAKE
AND HAS NO [inaudible]
RATIONAL [inaudible]
OF BASIS -- EDUCATION FUNDING
SYSTEMS PRESENT PRESENT BARRIERS
WERE THERE SHOULD BE
OPPORTUNITIES.
AGAIN DEBT FOR DECADES
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING RATES HAVE VARIED
CONSIDERABLY WITHOUT AGAIN ANY
RATIONALE.
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH
THESE INEQUITIES FOR NEARLY FOR
DEBT DECADES AND ADDRESSING THEM
AS A MATTER OF FAIRNESS.
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL ALSO PRESENTS A
BARRIER WERE AGAIN THERE SHOULD
BE OPPORTUNITY.
IT'S A CRITICAL TIME IN
CHILDREN'S LIVES AB FOR TWENTY
EIGHT PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
WITH MOST SEVERE DISABILITIES.
WHEN OUR CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE SYSTEM WAS
ESTABLISHED WE HAD SUPPORT BUT
THAT SUPPORT WAS ELIMINATED
DURING THE RECESSION?
LEAVING SCHOOLS WITH NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
HIGHER COSTS PLACEMENTS.
ALL OF THE ADJUSTMENTS IN THE
BILL THAT I AM PROPOSING ARE
COMMONSENSE INVESTMENTS AND
FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY FOR OUR
VALUED STUDENTS SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- AND AND
DOING AS MUCH AS WE CAN -- FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING AND
BUILDING ON THE WORK BY MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER O'DONNELL.
ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND I GUESS THIS LEADS
TO TO THE QUESTION THAT WE HAD.
SPECIAL HEARING ON THIS THIS
YEAR.
THIS IS THE LIKE EVERY YEAR THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR A
DISTRICTS WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT.
THE STRESS THEY'RE FACING.
WITH THEIR COSTS IN THE NEEDS OF
OUR KIDS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL ED AND WE WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION IN THE PROPOSAL.
AT AND I GUESS LINGERING ISSUE
IS IS THIS THE BEST APPROACH TO
GO FORWARD AND I AND WE HAVE
THIS.
EQUALIZATION IDEA ANOTHER
PROPOSAL SO WHEN ASKED APARTMENT
A FINANCE ARE YOU -- TAKING A
LOOK AT SOME SOME OTHER -- WAYS
TO TO ADDRESS -- SPECIAL LET
ISSUES AND AND THE INEQUITIES IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE MORE YOU SEE
SOMETHING NEW IN THE MAY REVISE.
YEAH GREAT QUESTION AB WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS PROPOSAL YOU
KNOW THERE THERE ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES IN SPECIAL EDUCATION --
THIS PROPOSAL DOESN'T PLAN TO
SOLVE ALL OF THOSE ISSUES THE
GOVERNOR AND THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS REALLY INTERESTED IN LOOKING
AT KIND OF THE COMPOUNDING
EFFECTS OF POVERTY RATE WHICH IS
WHY THIS PROPOSAL LOOKS AT HOW
YOU PP RATES THESE DISTRICTS.
THAT HAVE A LOT OF HIGH NEED
STUDENTS A LOT OF STUDENTS AND
POVERTY AND ON TOP OF THAT A LOT
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES --
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL KIND OF
LOOKS AT MAKING THIS TARGETED
INVESTMENT I THINK MOVING
FORWARD INTO THE MAY REVISED --
WE WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU THE LEGISLATURE ON ON
HOW DO WE SOLVE YOU KNOW THE
LARGER ISSUES OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION NOT JUST.
NOT JUST LOOKING AT THESE HIGH
NEED AREAS BUT LOOKING AT
UNEQUAL RATES LOOKING AT KIND OF
FUNDING FOR PRESCHOOL SOME OF
THE THINGS YOU MENTION.
THAT DEFINITELY BE WORKING WITH
YOU AND HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THE
FAIRNESS ISSUE THAT NOT.
ALL AND LIAISE WITH PARTICIPATE
IN THE FIRST PROPOSAL WHERE AS
THEY WOULD IF WE HAD THIS.
BECAUSE ASIAN.
BEES -- I THINK FOR THIS
PROPOSAL IT IS TARGETED SO LIKE
YOU MENTIONED NOT EVERYONE WOULD
BENEFIT -- I THINK FOR
EQUALIZATION GENERALLY AS AS FAR
AS I KNOW NOT EVERYONE WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THAT EITHER RIGHT
WHICH IS KIND OF SHIFTING
FUNDING -- FROM L. CFF INTO
SPECIAL EDUCATION -- AND WHERE
WE'RE BRINGING PEOPLE OUT BUT
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT BRINGING
EVERYONE UP AS WELL AND SO I
THINK.
THIS FUNDING IS MORE OF AN IT'S
IT'S EQUITY FOCUS IT'S WHERE THE
HIGH NEED AREAS WHERE THE HIGH
NEED STUDENTS LET'S PUT A LOT OF
FUNDING INTO THAT -- AND AGAIN
EQUALIZATION IS KIND OF A A
CONTINUE WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION AS MARY
VERSION.
COMES AT OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WELL THIS ISSUE OPEN.
NEXT ISSUE SCHOOL FACILITIES
.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED.
WITH BUDGET OVER -- LET'S SEE
THIS ONE WE ARE FINANCE.
THANK YOU CAN IT'S LA -- AND
THEN.
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU KEITH NIZAM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
AS YOU KNOW THE VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AUTHORIZING THE
SALE OF SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
BOND FUNDS TO SUPPORT K. TWELVE
SCHOOL FACILITY.
PROJECTS -- THREE BILLION DID
WAS DESIGNATED FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION THREE BILLION FOR
MODERNIZATION AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS EACH FOR CREE
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES.
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THE
STATE'S BURST FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF THESE
BOND FUNDS -- THE THAT'S MEMBERS
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS FIVE HER
NINETY FIVE MILLION -- AND IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE PROPOSE
A GOAL DISBURSING ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY AND EACH YEAR THEREAFTER
UNTIL THE BOND FUNDING IS
EXHAUSTED -- TO MEET THE
OBJECTIVE OR THE GOAL OF
DISBURSING ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN BOND FUNDS IN THE
BUDGET YEARS -- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- PROVIDES THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION WITH
TEN POSITIONS AND ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN BOND FUND
BOND FUNDING TO INCREASE THEIR
CAPACITY TO PROCESS THE DISH
APPLICATIONS NECESSARY.
TO DISPERSE THE ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
BOND FUNDING -- AS WE KNOW BONDS
ARE NOT ARE NOT FREE AND REQUIRE
A PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST
PAYMENTS ADVERTISE OVER THIRTY
YEAR PERIOD TYPICALLY -- IN --
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY THE
DEBT SERVICE FOR PROPOSITION
FIFTY ONE AND THE VARIOUS
PREVIOUS OKAY TWELVE FACILITY
BONDS -- IS TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND --
UP THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO BE
DISPERSED IN NINETEEN TWENTY
RESULT IN ANNUALIZED DEBT
SERVICE OF EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS -- PER YEAR FOR A TOTAL
OF POSSIBLY TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION OVER THAT THIRTY YEAR.
REPAYMENT PERIOD -- OF COURSE I
STATE BONDS ARE NOT THE ONLY --
FUNDING SOURCE FOR SCHOOLS TO
BUILD FACILITY TO MEET THEIR
FACILITY NEEDS -- ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEBT AND AND
INVESTMENT ADVISORY COMMISSION
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TO VOTE LOCAL
VOTERS HAVE PASSED -- OVER ONE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN LOCAL BONDS TO MEET THEIR
FACILITY NEEDS IN ADDITION
THERE'S ANOTHER ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
GENERATED THROUGH DEVELOPER FEES.
ON A COMMERCIAL RESIDENTIAL.
BUILDINGS -- AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY OVER.
GOOD MORNING AMY LEE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE ARE
YOU SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A
HANDOUT THAT WILL BE REFERENCING
THEIR ORDER PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING YEP THAT'S IT.
I WILL COVER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BOND SALE FIRST AND
THEN MOVE ON TO THE ASSOCIATED
STAFFING PROPOSAL THE STARTING
ON PAGE.
ONE THE SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED TWENTY ONE YEARS
AGO AS A WAY FOR THE STATE AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO SHARE COSTS
OF BUILDING NEW SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND RENOVATING OLD
ONES.
THE STATE PROVIDES FUNDING ON A
PER PUPIL BASIS AND COVERS IT
SHARE USING VOTER APPROVED
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS.
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SIX VOTERS
APPROVED THIRTY FIVE BILLION IN
STATE SCHOOL BONDS THIS BOND
FUNDING WAS EFFECTIVELY
EXHAUSTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE AND DESTRUCTION COVER
THEIR SHARE THROUGH LOCAL BONDS
APPROVED BY VOTERS.
MOVING ON TO PAGE.
TWO SO THIS COVERS AN OVERVIEW
OF PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE WHICH
FINANCE -- ALREADY SHARED THIS
IS THE MOST RECENTLY APPROVED
STATE SCHOOL BOND I THINK THE
ONLY THING WE WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION IS THAT THE STATE HAS
MADE TO INSTALL HAVE MADE
INSTALLMENTS OF PROPOSITION.
FIFTY ONE BOND SALES FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS SELLING UNDER SIX
HUNDRED MILLION FOR EACH OF
THOSE YEARS
IF THE STATE WERE TO CONTINUE AT
THIS PACE IT WOULD TAKE A TOTAL
OF TWELVE YEARS TO EXHAUST
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FINDS.
IN THE MEANTIME THE CITY HAS A
GROWING BACKLOG OF SCHOOL
FACILITY APPLICATIONS WITH ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IN
APPLICATION STILL AWAITING
PROCESSING AS OF THE END OF THIS
FEBRUARY.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
SELL THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN SCHOOL BONDS IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THIS PROPOSAL
WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO MORE
QUICKLY FIND PROJECTS WAITING IN
THE PIPELINE AND IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE LEVEL OF BOND SALES THE
LEGISLATURE DISCUSSED DURING
BUDGET HEARINGS LAST YEAR.
AT THIS PACE IT WOULD TAKE A
TOTAL OF SIX YEARS TOEXHAUST
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FINDS
WHICH IS A CELEBRATED COMPARED
TO TWELVE YEAR TIMELINE
PREVIOUSLY.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE HERE
WHAT WE START TO DISCUSS THE
GOVERNOR STAFFING PROPOSAL TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED INCREASE
MONTHS OUT.
AS YOU CAN SEE AND THE FIGURE ON
PAGE FOUR THERE ARE THREE MAIN
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN THE STATE'S
REVIEW PROCESS FOR THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROP PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
REVIEW SITE APPROVAL AND PLANS
FOR EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES.
THE DIVISION OF THE STATE
ARCHITECT REVIEWS PLANTS FOR
SAFETY AND ACCESSIBILITY
CONCERNS.
AND THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION -- PSE PROCESSES
SCHOOL FACILITY APPLICATIONS TO
DETERMINE FUNDING ELIGIBILITY
AND THEN PRESENTS PROJECTS TO
THE STATE ALLOCATION BOARD FOR
APPROVAL.
OPSEU CURRENTLY HAS FIFTY TWO
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS HALF OF
THEM ARE ASSIGNED TO THE AUDIT
DIVISION AND THE OTHER HALF ARE
SAYING TO THE PROGRAM SERVICES
DIVISION.
THE PROGRAM SERVICES DIVISION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROCESSING
APPLICATIONS AS WELL AS HANDLING
APPEALS PROGRAM POLICIES AN
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
MOVING ON TO PEACH.
FIVE THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE ONE POINT TWO MILLION --
FOR PSE TO HIRE TEN ADDITIONAL
STAFF FOR APPLICATION PROCESSING
THIS WOULD INCLUDE EIGHT
ANALYSTS AND TWO MANAGERS THIS
WOULD BE AN ON GOING
AUGMENTATION FROM POP IT
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FINDS. TWO
WEEKS AGO UPON REQUEST FROM
BUDGET STAFF OPC PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD INFORMATION
WHICH WERE STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF REVIEWING.
BASED ON INFORMATION THAT WAS
MADE AVAILABLE IN FEBRUARY
THOUGH WHEN WE COMPLETED OUR
ANALYSIS WE HAVE THREE MAIN
CONCERNS WITH THE STAFFING
PROPOSAL.
FIRST WE BELIEVE OPSEU DECADES
TO FEW STAFF TO APT TO BUY
APPLICATION PROCESSING CURRENTLY
ONLY TEN FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
EMPLOYEES OUT OF THE FIFTY TWO
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS ARE
DEDICATED TO THIS CORE FUNCTION.
THIS IS LESS THAN 20% OF ALL
POSITIONS.
SECONDLY WE HAVE A RELATED
CONCERN THAT THE REQUESTED TEN
NEW POSITIONS MORE THAN -- PSE
MAY NEED USING OPIATES SEES OWN
LOGIC AND ASSUMPTIONS USED IN
THAT ORIGINAL STAFFING PROPOSAL
WE ESTIMATE THAT THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN APPLICATIONS
COULD BE PROCESSED BY.
TWELVE EMPLOYEES WHICH IS ONLY
TWO MORE THAN OPC CURRENTLY
DEDICATES TO THIS FUNCTION.
WHEN WE BROUGHT UP THIS
DIFFERENCE OPS HE INDICATED TO
US THAT THERE IS ADDITIONAL WORK
ASSOCIATED WITH APPLICATION
PROCESSING?
INCLUDING.
UPDATING ELIGIBILITY FOR PROBE
FOR THE PROGRAM AND HANDLING
APPEALS THIS ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
WOULD HAVE TO BE RATHER HIGH
RELATIVE TO THE CITED TIME SPENT
PROCESSING APPLICATIONS.
THE POTENTIALLY JUSTIFY TEN NEW
POSITIONS.
FINALLY WE BELIEVE SOME
POSITIONS CAN BE RE DIRECTED TO
APPLICATION PROCESSING FROM --
PC'S AUDITING DIVISION.
THE PASS OPS HE WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR AUDITING PROJECTS TO VERIFY
THAT THEY COMPLY WITH PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS AND THE PROJECT
PROPOSALS ORIGINALLY APPROVED.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE STATE DEVOLVED
THESE ART RESPONSIBILITIES TO
LOCAL INDEPENDENT AUDITORS
WITHOUT ANY CORRESPONDING STAFF
REDUCTIONS -- TO PSE.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT -- PSE HAD
SOME WORK ASSOCIATE WITH
TRANSITIONING THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND IS STILL
WRAPPING UP SOME PROJECT
AUDIENCE.
HOWEVER AUDITING IS NO LONGER A
CORE FUNCTION OF THIS AGENCY YET
TWENTY FOUR POSITIONS ARE ALMOST
HALF OF ALL POSITIONS ARE STILL
HOUSED IN THE AUDIT DIVISION.
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTS THE OPC STAFFING
PROPOSAL BECAUSE WE FIND THAT IN
PC CAN MANAGE THE NEW WORKLOAD
USING EXISTING RESOURCES.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
HI LISA STILL BERMAN I'M GET
WITH THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION.
YEAH I LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED ON BY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AS FAR AS A STAFFING LEVELS ARE
CONCERNED AND WANTED DEFINITELY
CLARIFY.
THAT THERE ARE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY ARE NOT TWENTY FOUR
ANA POSITIONS IN THE AGENCY SO.
FIRST I I WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY SIX WERE
OVERSTATED THEY'RE ACTUALLY SIX
ANALYST IN THAT AREA -- THAT
WERE INITIALLY -- DESIGNATED FOR
ASSISTING WITH THE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE OF WHAT WE
CALL THE K. TWELVE AUDIT SUPPORT.
AT THOSE FOLKS ARE ACTUALLY
PROCESSING APPLICATIONS AND THEN
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A SEVEN
EQUIVALENT MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS AN ACT.
AREA WE HAD ELEVEN DESIGNATED
AUDITOR'S.
THAT WOULD INITIALLY ASSIGNED TO
THAT AREA WE HAVE TWO VACANCIES --
WONDERS VACANCIES ARE CONVERTED
TO AN ACCOUNTING OFFICER VACANCY
AND ACTUALLY WILL BE FILLED --
PROBABLY WITH THE NEXT TWO DAYS.
DUE TO THE IMPENDING WORKLOAD --
AND THEN WE ACTUALLY HAVE ONE
AUDITOR ON A LIMITED TERM
ASSIGNMENT -- IN OUR ENTERPRISE
TECHNOLOGY M. AREA SO WE HAVE TO
KEEP THAT VACANCY POSED A VACANT --
FOR THE NEXT I WOULD BELIEVE
IT'S SIDE TWENTY TWENTY
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY SO WE
CAN'T FILL THAT VACANCY AT THIS
POINT THEM UNLESS AT CANDID IT
IS SUCCESSFUL WITH THE
TRANSITION -- AND THAT
CLASSIFICATION SO AGAIN WE DON'T
HAVE THEM THAT PICKED POSITION
OPEN AT THIS POINT TIME.
SO I ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY WHAT
OUR ROLE IS -- YES THEREIS
FIFTY TWO STAFF POSITIONS IN OUR
AREA AND IF WE WERE JUST PROCESS
THE NEW CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION -- FRANCE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A MUCH EXPANDED
ROLE WE ACTUALLY HAVE CAREER
TECH.
RAM GRANTS AS WELL -- THERE IS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AUTHORIZED -- AS PART OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE SO WE
STILL HAVE A OPEN FINALLY AROUND
AND WE STILL HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WERE ACTUALLY WILL
BE PROCESSING -- TO THE MAY
BOARD TO ACTUALLY TAKE STAFF
ALLOCATION AND HOURS TO PROCESS
THOSE AT THE PROGRAM GRANTS WE
STILL HAVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- IN FUTURE
FUNDING TO ALLOCATE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS WELL AND THAT TAKES
STAFFING TIME -- AS WELL AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF HILLS I
WOULD SAY -- ON AVERAGE TWO TO
THREE APPEALS GO TO THE BOARD
EVERY MONTH OTHERS ALSO APPEALS
TO GET RESOLVED MINISTRY TO FLEE --
THERE'S A NUMBER REGULATIONS
THAT WE BRING FORWARD TO THE
BOARD I WOULD SAY THREE TO FOUR
ON AVERAGE EVERY YEAR -- BUT
ALSO -- TAKES ABOUT TIME AND
EFFORT -- THERE'S ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY GRAND AGREEMENTS
HAVE ALSO PROCESS TO THE BOARD --
THAT WAS ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
THAT WASN'T ANTICIPATED DONE THE
BOARDED UP TO GRANT AGREEMENT
WHICH IS GREAT.
PROVIDE CLARITY TO THE PROGRAM
BUT AGAIN THAT'S ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD THAT -- WE ARE STAFFING
THEM -- TO AND AGAIN THAT'S
ADDITIONAL WORK BUT THEY WERE
PROCESSING AS WELL.
THERE'S CHARTER PROJECTS THAT
ARE CONVERTING -- SO WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE THAT -- SO THERE'S
WEBSITE -- PUBLICATIONS THOSE AT
A PUBLICATIONS THAT AS WELL
THERE'S BUSINESS SERVICES IS
MAIL ROOM THERE'S ACCOUNTING
STAFF AGAIN I JUST WANT THERE'S
A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS THAT WE
DO SO.
JUST TO PUT IN PERSPECTIVE --
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
AS FAR AS THE AUDITS CONCERN WE
STILL HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN CLOSE OUT ON ITS THAT
ARE.
AGAIN OUR STE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE PROJECTS
THAT WERE FUNDED PRIOR TO APRIL
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALTHOUGH I
DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT -- THE
CLOTHES OUT FUNCTIONS DID SHIFT --
TO THE LOCAL WATERS -- THERE ARE
PRIOR PRIOR PROJECTS AGAIN THAT
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
AUDIT THOSE PROJECTS.
AND THAT THAT IS THE BURDEN OF
OUR STAFF -- WE HAVE THAT NINE
AUDITOR'S ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
WORKLOAD.
AND ALSO WE ACTUALLY HAVE -- AS
FAR AS SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS
CHECKS WE HAVE THE CASE TWELVE
AUDIT SUPPORT.
AND AGAIN -- WITH THE NEW
PROGRAM WE ACTUALLY AGAIN HAVE
TO EDUCATE AND TRAIN.
THE LA ETS AND THE CPA'S -- OUT
THERE ON THE NEW HONOR
REQUIREMENTS -- THAT JUST DIDN'T
HAPPEN ALL BY ITSELF --
DISTRICTS WANT TO KNOW WHAT --
WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS ARE AND
HOW TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE NEW
PROGRAM SO AGAIN THAT TAKES A A
LOT OF EFFORT AND TIME?
AND THEY ALSO WANT TO HAVE A
SOFT REVIEW OF THEIR EXPENDITURE
REPORTS AND AGAIN TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO GET IN A AND
ARE ON IT -- WE HAVE AT LEAST
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY OR PLUS
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS JACKSON
AGAIN THE LOCAL WATERS DIDN'T
WANT ASSUME THAT RESPONSIBILITY
SINCE WE ARE THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS.
ANY ANY ADDITIONAL CHANGES
MOVING FORWARD IN THE K. TWELVE
BODY GUY WILL BE -- OUR SOLE
RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL -- I ALSO
WANT TO SHARE -- ADDITIONAL
COMPONENT AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF
APPLICATION PROCESS SAY IN.
THIS DISTRICTS THAT ARE SEEKING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP ASSISTANCE
AND THAT ALSO IS A ALSO
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE AUDIT
STAFF SO WHAT DOES THAT ENTAIL
THAT IS -- FRONT IN REVIEW TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH OF THE
DISTRICTS OR THE L. A.'S HAVE.
FUNDS AVAILABLE AND SO THAT
DETERMINATION GOES HAND IN HAND
WITH THE GRANT PROCESSING SO IF
THERE'S ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OF GRANT PROCESSING IN
THE FRONT END.
THERE'S FORTY THREE DISTRICTS
WITHIN THAT GROUP BEING THAT
WILL SEEK -- STATE ASSISTANCE
FOR THE MATCH AND THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN WITHOUT THE ON IT STAFF.
SO I WANTTO SHARE THAT WITH YOU --
ANOTHER COMPOUND IT IS FAR AS
OUR STAFFING NEEDS -- AS FAR AS
REQUESTING TEN ADDITIONAL STAFF --
THAT WE HAVE -- ADDED VALUE TO
WHAT WE DO I'M IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT OF WHY WE NEED TO HAVE
OUR STAFF ADDITIONAL STAFF TO
PROCESS APPLICATIONS.
OUT OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE
PROCESS A HUNDRED EIGHTIES
APPLICATIONS AN OUT OF THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
APPLICATIONS. FORTY NINE
RESULTED IN ADDITIONAL GRANTS
THAT WERE PROVIDED TO ELLIE ETS
WHICH IS GREAT NEWS -- SIXTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL GRANTS WERE AWARDED
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO SHARE A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE PROJECTS
RESULTED IN A NET REDUCTION.
IN THEIR GRANTS SO WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN SOME OF THE GRANTS
THEY WERE ENTITLED.
TO AND THAT RESULTED IN A
HUNDRED AND HUNDRED ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN A REDUCTION
IN THE PROJECT REQUEST.
SO THAT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT SO
AGAIN WE ADD VALUE AND AGAIN.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECTS OF THE GRANTS THAT WE
ALLOWED IN OUR PROGRAM.
AGAIN OUR ALLEYS ARE ENTITLED TO
SO AGAIN WE HAVE SAFEGUARDS IN
OUR PROGRAM AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROCESSING
GRANTS THAT DISTRICTS ARE
ENTITLED.
TO THERE TWENTY SIX GRANTS ARE
PROCESS AS WELL THAT DIDN'T
REQUIRE ANY CHANGE AT ALL SO
AGAIN EIGHTY SIX POINT -- ONE OF
THE REVIEWS DID REQUIRE SOME NET
RESULT CHANGE SO AGAIN I WANT TO
SHARE THAT WITH YOU.
OKAY WE'LL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
AS WELL.
I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
ITEM -- SO THAT THAT CONCLUDES
THE THE FIVE ISSUE ITEMS FOR
TODAY.
NO ACTION ITEMS WILL PROCEED NOW
WITH PUBLIC COM [inaudible]
YEAH
.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED GOOD MORNING
I'M CHARLEY HOFFMAN.
BY THE WAY GET SORRY. ONE MINUTE
OR LESS THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU.
I'M A FROM READING I
SUPERINTENDENT SHASTA TRINITY
ROP AND SUPER TUNER BELLAVISTA
ELEMENTARY -- SPEAKING TODAY A
SPECIFICALLY THE CT A GRANT
ISSUE AND IN SUPPORT IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
THIRTEEN OH THREE OUR OUR OUR P.
CONTINUES TO EXIST BECAUSE OF C.
TAG -- SOLVING A LONG TERM
DEFICIT THAT WE WOULD HAVE
FOLDED BY NOW WITHOUT IT WE
APPLIED FOR THIS SHE TO GRANT
THIS WINTER.
THE APPLICATION TOOK ABOUT THREE
HOURS AND WE NOTED ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IT WILL
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
INDEFINITELY WE ALSO APPLIED FOR
THE STRONG WORKFORCE CAGE WEALTH --
NINE TWELVE GRANT AND THAT
APPLICATION TOOK ABOUT A HUNDRED
HOURS IN WILL YIELD ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR IS
IF WE GET EVERYTHING WE ASKED.
FOR AND WE WILL NOT BE A PLAN
FOR IT AGAIN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
COLLAPSING THE STRONG WORK FORCE.
GRANT INTO THE SEA TECH THANK
YOU YES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JULIE
DARK AND I REPRESENT C. T. AND
R. O. P. FOR DUBLIN LIVERMORE
VALLEY JOINT AND PLUS TO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
REPROACH OF AB THIRTEEN NO.
THREE ON GOING FUNDING WITH
ANNUAL ACCOUNTABILITY ENABLES
YOU TO MAINTAIN AND IMPROVE CT
PROGRAM SYSTEMATICALLY THE WAY
IN WHICH THE INCENTIVE GRANT WAS
DESIGNED.
THIS THIS IS PUT IN PLACE BY THE
CD OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
AND ABEL'S DISTRICTS TO RECEIVE
THE TRAINING AND THE TOOLS. TO
DEVELOP MAINTAIN ENHANCE THEIR
C. T. PROGRAMS IN ALL MY YEARS
IN EDUCATION I'VE NEVER BEEN
MORE IMPRESSED THE LEVEL SUPPORT.
AND CONSISTENCY ALL LEVELS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN REGARDS THE
INCENTIVE GRANT.
THE METRICS WERE CLEAR AND
FOCUSED ON THE ELEMENTS THAT
MAKE UP A HIGH QUALITY C. T.
PROGRAM WHICH INCLUDE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNICABLE
IT'S THROUGH ARTICULATIONS DUAL
ENROLLMENT.
AND WITH THE EMPLOYEES OR THE
EMPLOYERS THROUGH AN INDUSTRY
ADVISORY COMMITTEES WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES WHICH
INCLUDES INTERNET INTERNSHIPS
AND CERTIFICATIONS AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY IS ALIGNED TO THE
COLLAGEN CORE INDICATOR.
I UNDERSTAND THE MAP MACHEL WERE
HANDED THIS SB W. PETE
LEGISLATION AND HAD TO MAKE THE
BEST WHAT THEY WERE GIVEN
HOWEVER WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
CORRECT WHAT MOST SEE IS AN
ACCESS AND EQUITY ISSUE.
IN PLACE THE CT DOLLARS FOR K.
TWELVE TO THE CD THANK YOU.
HELLO LA LONNIE I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY JPA COALITION
AND HE BACKING ON THE REMARKS
THAT WERE ALREADY GIVEN BY
CHILEAN CHARLIE WE DO HAVE
STRONG CONCERNS WITH US K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
WE BELIEVE IT ESTABLISHES
ANOTHER LAYER OF BUREAUCRACY
THAT DOES NOT ADD VALUE TO HIGH
QUALITY AND K. TWELVE C. T.
PROGRAMS AND DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
SUSTAINABILITY -- AS ASSEMBLYMAN
O'DONNELL ARE EXPRESSED YOU CAN
ONLY APPLY FOR FUNDS IF YOU'RE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AGREES TO WORK
WITH YOU.
I'M AND YET FUNDING IS PARTIALLY
BASED ON EIGHTY A IN THE REGION
AND ADDITIONALLY OF THE GRANT
METRICS -- FOR THE U. K. TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM THEY
ARE THE SAME AS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM METRICS WHICH MEANS THAT.
AND THERE IS A LONG DELAY AND
IDENTIFYING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
OUR K. TWELVE C. T. PROGRAMS
SOMETIMES AS MANY AS FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS LATER BECAUSE
SEVERAL OF THE METRICS ARE MEANT
TO BE MET.
AFTER A STUDENT HAS COMPLETED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND FINALLY ON
MANY OF THE METRICS DON'T EVEN
CONSIDER STUDENTS WHO ENROLL IN
UNIVERSITY OR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MCCARTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
US TO BE HERE TODAY I'M DOCTOR
PAULING WILL CURRENTLY SERVE AS
A STATE PRESTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION.
ADMINISTRATOR ASSOCIATION AND
THE PRINCIPLE OF ABC ABOUT
SCHOOL THANK YOU HURT -- I
HUMBLY AND DELLA RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU TO CONSIDER THE
FUNDING PROPOSAL WE PUT FORWARD
FULL ONE HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONGOING SUPPORT FOR THE
ADULT EDUCATION.
ALTHOUGH IT OCCASION LACKEY YEAR
HER TO FROM THE PANELISTS
ALREADY SHOW AND INCREASE OF 10%
ENROLLMENT AND STRONG ALL COMES
WITH THIS REGULAR LIMITED FI
HIRING MEDIAN DOLLARS SAW.
OF FUNDING WE ARE LOOKING INTO
6% INCREASE UP THE ONGOING
PERSONNEL COST AND MY SCHOOL IS
A 6% AND WE RECEIVED THREE POINT.
FOUR SIX OUR COAL OUT FOR THE
NEXT YEAR WE APPRECIATE THAT
PART BUT STILL WHITE YOU KNOW
ONE PLANE FLIGHT ADULTS AS STILL
LOOKING FOR JOBS THREE POINT
FIVE A THREE POINTFOUR MILLION
ADULTS.
MEETS THE ESL CLASSES AND FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION ADULTS ARE
STILL LOOKING HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA WORKING ALL AND NOT
COUNTY A LOT OF THE HOLDS.
A READING AT THAT BELOW SEVEN'S
GREAT LEVEL SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S AYE INCREASED
INVESTMENT SPECIAL EDUCATION
ALTHOUGH WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE FUNDS DIRECTED TOWARDS THE
WORK FORCE.
PARTICULARLY ARE PARA EDUCATORS
WHO WORK DAILY WITH US THE
NEEDIEST STUDENTS WE'VE SEEN
STRONG INVESTMENTS IN LAUSD FOR
INSTANCE WHERE THEY CONTRACTED
OUT WORK FOR PARA EDUCATORS WHEN
THEY DIDN'T HAVE BE AYE TRAINING --
LA WAS DE CREATE A PROGRAM WHERE
ARE PARA EDUCATORS GET THAT
EDUCATION AND TRAINING AND BRING
THE WORK BACK IN HOUSE THAT
PROVIDES A STABLE ENVIRONMENT
FOR KIDS THAT NEED A STABLE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND ALSO SAVE THE MILLIONS WE
ALSO HAVE HERE TODAY HAVE UP
HERE EDUCATORS FROM NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TALK ABOUT
THEIR EXPERIENCE THANK YOU.
MORNING JOE MCCARTY IN ARNOLD I
REPRESENT SEIU LOCAL TEN TWENTY
ONE WORKERS AT SACRAMENTO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WHERE OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF SPECIAL ED KIDS WERE
VERY FRAGILE MEDICALLY NEEDY AND
SOME CAN BECOME VIOLENT WHEN
OVER STIMULATED?
BECAUSE THE DISTRICT IS NOT
CURRENTLY FUNDED AT THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL FOR SPECIAL ED.
WE'RE TAKING THE MONEY FOR THAT
PROGRAM FROM OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
ARE JUST AS NEEDY BUT WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY FUNDING TO THE EXTENT
NEEDED WERE FUNDING ONLY THE
MINIMUM POSSIBLE LEVEL.
WHICH IS NOT SAFE FOR THE KIDS
AND IT'S NOT SAFE FOR THE STAFF
IN FACT -- IN MY EXPERIENCE HERE
SECOND CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE LARGEST SINGLE
NUMBER OF INDUSTRIAL INJURIES
WORKERS COMP INJURIES HAPPENS
WITH SPECIAL ED PARA
PROFESSIONALS NOT THE FOLKS
YOU'RE BREAKING UP FIGHTS IN THE
SCHOOL YARD.
BUT THE FOLKS WHO ACTUALLY
ASSISTING THOSE KIDS.
SO WE NEED TO FIX THIS WOULD
MAKE SURE THE IDENTIFIED FUNDING
STREAM SO IT CAN SP.
WE CAN CORRECTLY FUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION THANK YOU.
THIS MCCARTY -- MIKE BEVERLY --
PARA PROFESSIONAL AID THE
BURBANK HIGH SCHOOL I WOULD JUST
LIKE OVER MY EIGHT PLUS YEARS OF
WORKING WITH.
THE HIGH SCHOOL I'VE BEEN PUT IN
SITUATIONS WERE -- NOT ONLY HAVE
I BEEN THE ONLY AID IN THE
CLASSROOM.
WITH NO TEACHER SOMETIMES --
I'VE ALSO HAD POINTS WERE --
I'VE HAD STUDENTS -- STAB ME IN
THE FORM OF THE PENCIL AND
DURING ONE FIGHT.
I'VE HAD STUDENTS THROW CHAIRS
AT ME.
AND I'VE BEEN THE BEING.
RATHER YOU KNOW LARGER THAN THE
REST OF THE PARA PROFESSIONALS
THAT I WORK WITH -- I WAS SETS
TASK WITH TAKING CARE OF THE
SITUATION.
AND I HONESTLY I WAS NOT
PREPARED FOR SOME OF THESE
SITUATIONS.
I WAS TOLD UPON -- HIRING OF OF
THIS POSITION FROM FOR MYSELF
THAT -- BECAUSE I EARLIER WORK
SECURITY THAT I WOULDN'T NEED.
MY EXPERIENCE WORKING SECURITY.
AND I FIND THAT NOT TO BE
ENTIRELY TRUE BECAUSE THERE ARE
TIMES WHERE.
I'VE HAD.
TO KIND OF KEEP.
STUDENTS AWAY FROM OTHER
STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN --
DISTURBANCE OR VIOLENT
[inaudible]
AND I DIDN'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
TO DO I DIDN'T HAVE THE GUIDANCE.
THAT I WOULD NEED TO DO THAT.
SO I JUST I WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR THAT.
HAVE SOMETHING PUT IN PLACE TO
WHERE WE CAN EDUCATE OTHER
PREPARE PARA PROFESSIONALS AS TO
WHAT TO DO IN THIS SITUATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
SCHROEDER AND I WORK AT JOHN
MORRIS THERAPEUTIC CENTER IT'S
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR
CHILDREN -- MARSHALL
DISTURBANCES SO WE DO HAVE SOME
TRAINING AS FAR AS HOW TO WORK
WITH AND GHASTLY CHILDREN AND
AND DEAL WITH THEM IF THEY'RE
NOT.
I SO WE'RE LUCKY ON THAT BEHALF.
ASSEMBLY MY STUDENTS JUST DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
SUPPORT.
WE COULD USE A LOT MORE
EDUCATION AND HOW TO ASSIST THEM
IN THE CLASSROOM -- OUTSIDE
SUPPORT AND THAT IS NEVER REALLY --
HELPFUL HONESTLY BECAUSE IT GETS
THEM OFF THEIR SCHEDULES IT GETS
THEM OFF THEIR ROUTINES WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO HAVE --
ONE MY STUDENTS DON'T HAVE A
VOICE SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
TO HELP THEM.
WE NEED -- TO WE NEED MORE
[inaudible]
AND OF THE KIDS DESERVE MORE.
SO THAT'S WHY I'M HERE KEEP.
HI MY NAME IS TO A JACKSON MISS
SPECIALISES IN FOR WILL LAKE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL -- VALUE WAS
THE AND I'M ALSO IS THAT THE
BOARD MEMBER OF LOCAL NINE NINE
S. YEAH YOU LOOK -- NINE NINE I
A SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S%
PROPOSAL HOWEVER THE STUDENTS I
WORK WITH ARE SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE DISTRICT THEY
REQUIRED DIRECT AND CONSTANT
CARE AND SUPPORT.
OUR STUDENTS DESERVES BETTER --
NOW IS THE TIME TO INVEST IN
TRAINING FOR SPECIAL IT WORKERS
IN HOUSE RATHER THAN OUTSOURCING
BE AYE AYES THE KEY TO STRONG
EDUCATION FOR OUR CHILDREN.
IS A WELL EDUCATED WORKFORCE.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH PARKER I
HAVE BEEN WITH THE DISTRICT FOR
LA U. S. T. FOR THIRTY YEARS I
AM SCA YOU MEMBER.
I AM FOCUSING ON SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUDGET BUDGET I AM
ACCESS FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION TRAINING
TO KEEP OUR WORK IN HOUSE.
PROVIDED STABILITY IN CARE FOR
ENSURING THAT OUR CHILDREN
RECEIVE THE BEST CARE FOR
EDUCATION SO THAT WE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN EDUCATION THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LEASES
LOAN I'M A SPECIAL EDUCATION
ASSISTANT AT LAUREL MENTERI
SCHOOL ON AND I AM ALSO A MEMBER
OF SEIU LOCAL -- NINETY NINE
SPECIFICALLY IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR SECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT -- LIKE
I SAID I'M A SPECIAL EDUCATION
ASSISTANT I WORK DIRECTLY WITH
US STUDENTS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU GUYS FIRST
HAND THAT.
THE EDUCATION THAT SOME OF THE
PROPER PROFESSIONALS THAT HAVE
ALREADY IS NOT ENOUGH FOR A WHAT
WE DO ON A DAILY BASIS.
THE YOUNG MINDS THAT WE
ENCOUNTER WITH.
ON CAN ENCOUNTER THEMSELVES
DRAMATIC OF EXPERIENCES THEY CAN
HAVE A LIFETIME AFFECT AND IF WE
HAVE THE PROPER TOOLS TO ENRICH
THEM SO THAT THEY CAN DO THE
SAME WITH THEIR LIVES.
THAT'S A STEP FORWARD THAT WE
CAN DO IN OUR COMMUNITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR NANCY TRIED AS A
SPIN OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING CASH AND I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE K. TWELVE FACILITIES
PORTION OF YOUR PRESENTATION
TODAY.
I'LL BEGIN WITH THE STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS -- IT'S CLEAR THAT
THE INFORMATION IS STILL IN FLUX
AND THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
RECEIVING NEW INFORMATION WE
SURE APPRECIATE THE THE INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE'RE SEEING --
CACHES POSITION IS -- PARTLY IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE PROPOSAL WE
DO SUPPORT THE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ONE POINT.
FIVE MILLION AUGMENTATION FOR
THE IT TEN ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
THAT -- PSE -- AT THE SAME TIME
WE DO AGREE WITH LA IS ANALYSIS
THAT -- THE OVERALL ALLOCATION
OF STAFFING DOES NOT APPEAR TO
BE IN LINE WITH THE CORE
FUNCTION OF OPSEC AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AS THE ANALYSIS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MOVES FORWARD THAT WE LOOK FOR
OTHER WAYS TO WORK WITH AN
EXISTING RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE
CAN WE DO MORE SHIFTING OF
POSITIONS NOT JUST WITH NO PST
BUT WITHIN THE GREATER
DEPARTMENT.
GENERAL SERVICES -- AND YOU KNOW
WE WE JUST HEARD SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM -- OPSEC FROM A
SILVERMAN FOR EXAMPLE -- WITH
EACH WHICH TELLS US IF IN FACT
THERE ARE MORE POSITIONS
PROCESSING APPLICATIONS THAT
THAT JUST MAKES US THINK THE
PRODUCTIVITY REALLY SHOULD BE
BETTER THAN WHAT IT IS -- OUR
ANALYSIS IS BASED ON HISTORICAL
OUTPUT HISTORICAL APPORTIONMENT
OF PROP FIFTY OF EXCUSE ME OF S.
OF P. APPLICATIONSSO WE DO
SUPPORT -- THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN -- BOND SALES AND
CORRESPONDING APPORTIONMENT BUT
FRANKLY WE THINK THAT -- THE
STATE CAN DO EVEN BETTER THAN
THAT -- THE BACKLOG OF COURSE IS
APPROACHING FIVE BILLION -- IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS COUPLE OF
DECADES THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN --
ASKING OUR EDUCATORS TO CHANGE
THE WAY THAT THEY DO THEIR JOB
SO TEACHERS ARE NOW REQUIRED TO
TEACH IN A DIFFERENT WAY AND
STUDENTS NEED ADEQUATE
FACILITIES TO DO THAT TO TEACH
COMMON CORE.
NDSS YES SIR.
SO THE URGENCY IS REAL -- WE ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO DELIVER ON THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE%
COMMITTEE ON FINANCE AND ALEJO.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A
HAND OUT MISTER CHAIR AND AND
THE MEMBERS IT JUST SHOWS -- FOR
YOUR PARTICULAR DISTRICT -- WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE TO A PORTION --
ALL OF THESE PROJECTS THAT ARE
WAITING IN THE QUEUE YEAR BY
YEAR.
LETS BUT THAT'S ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION HOWEVER WE WANT TO SEE
THAT MONEY BE REDIRECTED INTO AB
FOR TWENTY EIGHT WE ARE A CO
SPONSOR OF THAT BILL.
AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
FUNDING GO INTO A TO THAT BILLS
I'M IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
ALSO SUPPORTED THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN --
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE RELEASING
THOSE FUNDS WERE ALSO URGING THE
GOVERNOR AND ADMINISTRATION TO
RELEASE THEM SOON SO THAT WE CAN --
EXPEDITE THOSE PROJECTS THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS INTO
DEAL WITH THE COUNTY SCHOOL
FACILITIES CONSORTIUM -- WE WILL
ALSO OBVIOUSLY ALSO BECAUSE
COMMENTING ON THE OF FACILITIES --
AGENDA ITEM -- COUNTY OFFICES
ARE -- SERVE A VERY -- UNIQUE
AND SPECIFIC -- POPULATION AND
SO -- OF AND ALSO DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO RAISE LOCAL FUNDS SO --
STATE FUNDING IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION SO A VERY QUICKLY WE
SUPPORT THE THE ONE THAT IS
CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR'S ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION.
AND GOING BEYOND THAT.
CERTAINLY THAT AND WE SUPPORT
THE ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL FUNDING
PROPOSAL THAT HAS BEEN
REFERENCED -- MOM IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- JEFF
PARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS A YOU HAVE A LETTER
FROM A NUMBER OF COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION FINANCE
THAT WE ARE A PART OF WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
BUT WE DO SHARE MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE OUTLINED
TODAY BY THE LA -- AND ARE
OUTLINED IN YOUR ANALYSIS WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BEING TARGETED TOWARD
EQUITY -- WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THE PROPOSAL IN FACT WOULD
EXACERBATE THE INEQUITIES THAT
ALREADY EXIST.
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT WOULD
TRANSLATE INTO TEN OF OUR TWENTY
THREE DISTRICTS NOT BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FUNDING.
UNLIKE PREVIOUS SPEAKER WE TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
ANY OF FUNDING DIRECTED TOWARD
SPECIAL EDUCATION SHOULD INCLUDE
A COMPONENT TOWARD EQUALIZATION.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I'M ERIN EVANS ON
BEHALF OF THE SELF
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
CHILDREN WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS --
AND CHILDREN IN GENERAL AND WE
ALSO APPRECIATE ALL FUNDING
PROPOSE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES WE ARE CONCERNED
HOWEVER THAT THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE CONCENTRATION GRANT PROGRAM.
COULD EXACERBATE FUNDING
INEQUITIES AS YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
IN THE PREVIOUS PRESENTATION --
WE ARE PREPARING RECOMMENDATIONS
TO SUBMIT TO YOU IN WRITING
WHICH WILL BE COMING FORWARD IN
THE NEXT.
AND THE NEXT FEW DAYS -- AMONG
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE PER
ABA FUNDING FOR PRESCHOOLERS
WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS.
IN LINE WITH  BEFORE TWENTY
EIGHT AS WELL AS FULLY FUNDING
OF AB IS OF THE AB SIX OH TWO
FORMULA.
AND ELIMINATION OF THE PROBATION
FACTOR AND FINALLY I HAVE
FUNDING FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY
COSTS POOL AGAIN WILL BE
SUBMITTING THOSE TO IN WRITING
THANK.
GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
OF THE FACT THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ASSOCIATION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL EDUCATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR STRONG WORK FORCE
HOWEVER WERE DEEPLY CONCERNED
WITH THE USE OF ONE TIME MONEY
FOR STRONG WORK FORCE -- MOST
NOTABLY WERE CONCERNED WITH WEAR
THEM THE CONTINUE FUNDING WILL
COME FROM NEXT YEAR AND WHETHER
OR NOT THIS MAY HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF C.
T. IN THE FUTURE.
CHAU WORKFORCE IS BEEN A GAME
CHANGER FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND OUR INSTITUTIONS DEPEND ON
IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GERMAN I'M JEFF FROST
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION AND THE SUBURBAN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT THE LA OWES --
COMMENTS ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WE DO SUPPORT -- EQUALIZATION
BUT WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS.
ARE COVERED WITH -- ANY PROGRAM
THAT YOU -- YOU END UP WITH OF
REGARDING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION -- WE SUPPORT AB --
THIRTEEN OH THREE WE THINK THAT
IT'S CRITICAL THAT IT BECOME.
OPERATED UNDER ONE PROGRAM IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF ED BUT THAT
REGIONAL PROGRAMS SHOULD BE
MAINTAINED.
AND REGARDING SCHOOL FACILITIES --
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT --
HOW QUICKLY THE PROP FIFTY ONE
FUNDS ARE GETTING OUT -- WE
BELIEVE THAT MORE STAFFING --
PER THE LA OWES COMMENTS IS
APPROPRIATE -- AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
FOR SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- IN
THE APPLICATION PROCESSTHANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR STAFF
MICHAEL HOLE SIZE OR ON BEHALF
OF THE FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND KERN COUNTY.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY WANT TO
COMMEND STAFF FOR AN OUTSTANDING
ANALYSIS ON SPECIAL EDUCATION.
WE ARE IN COMPLETE AGREEMENT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND
MISTER MEDINA THROUGH AB FOR
TWENTY EIGHT THAT THE ONE
CORRECT SOLUTION FOR THIS
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR.
IS TO ADDRESS THE INEQUITY IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING FROM
THE STATE WHICH MAKES UP ABOUT
30% OF ALL FUNDING. FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT INEQUITY IS THE
ONE THING THAT WE BELIEVE THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DO TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
FOR MISTER CHAIR MY DILLON
REPRESENTS THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WOULD
JUST ECHO -- MISTER HALL SIZES
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
ANALYST A RECOMMENDATION AND
MISTER MEDINA'S BILL -- SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING IS THE MOST
PRESSING NEED IN SAN JOAQUIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON THE OFF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING TO THE SCHOOL
FACILITIES.
ITEM -- YEAH.
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE FACILITIES
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND SO ANY.
NEW FUNDING THROUGH THE BOND
PROGRAM WOULD-- BE APPRECIATED
WE ALSO WOULD NOTE THAT -- WE'RE
LOOKING AT A POTENTIAL SHORTFALL
THIS YEAR OF ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CHARTER
FACILITY GRANT PROGRAM -- THAT
WOULD RESULT IN A LOT OF CUTS TO
OUR SCHOOLS RETROACTIVELY AND
WOOD -- POTENTIALLY PUT MORE
PRESSURE ON THE BOND PROGRAM AND
ON DISTRICTS IN THEIR PROP
THIRTY NINE OBLIGATIONS AND SO
WE THINK.
FULLY FUNDING THAT PROGRAM --
WHICH WOULD SERVE EVERYBODY BASS
THANKS
CASEY TAYLOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ACHIEVE CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
PARADISE ALSO SPEAKING TO THE
FACILITIES ITEM.
AND WE SERVE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY K. TO NINTH GRADE STUDENTS
IN PARADISE 44% FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH AND RIGHT NOW A 100% OF MY
STUDENTS ARE QUALIFIED AS
HOMELESS BECAUSE OF THE CAMPFIRE.
WE'RE IN A NEARBY CITY IN CHICO
BUT HAVE PLANS TO GO BACK TO
PARADISE SB SEVEN FORTY
FACILITIES GRANT FUNDING.
HAS ALLOWED US TO KEEP OUR
RESOURCES FOCUS ON STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS INSTEAD OF ON RENT.
AND AND OF FULLY FUNDING THAT IS
GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT IMPACT
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM.
ESPECIALLY IN PARADISE OUR
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY GET BACK TO
PARADISE WE NEED THAT FULL SB
SEVEN FORTY FUNDING WITH THE
INCREASED COSTS IN THE
REBUILDING OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE COMMUNITY IS COUNTING ON
US TO GET BACK THERE ACTUALLY TO
RECRUIT FAMILIES BACK TO
PARADISE AS IT REBUILDS SO WE
ASK YOU TO WORK WITH A CASF A ON
FULLY FUNDING THAT IN THE MAY
REVISE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR PAMELA
GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ON THE FIRST ITEM
PERTAINING TO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION -- INCENTIVE GRANT OF
LOCAL SUPPORTS -- MOVING THE
WORK FORCE OF FUNDING FOR K.
TWELVE BACK TO CD E. WE HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING AND THE SERVICES
TO STUDENTS FOR MANY YEARS WE'VE
SUPPORTED LEGISLATION LAST YEAR --
AND LOOK TO SUPPORT LEGISLATION
THIS YEAR TO DO THAT WE ALSO
THINK THAT THE STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING WILL ALLOW.
THE PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE TO HIRE --
PEOPLE TO SERVE AND TEACH THE
CTE PROGRAM SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE VERY INTERESTED IN.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN LAKE -- PROVIDED SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX A C. T. E.
R. CREDENTIALS SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT HELPING MOVE
FORWARD SO WE ARE JUST SUPPORT
THERE.
AS FAR SPECIAL EDUCATION WE ARE
INTERESTED IN THE GOVERNORS HAVE
FUNDING THAT HE PROVIDED A IN
THE BUDGET THE FIVE AND SEVEN
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS BUT WE DO
WANT TO SEE.
THE ECLIPSE SPECIAL EQUIP THE
EQUALIZATION FORMULA GO FORWARD
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE ARE
SUPPORTING.
ALTHOUGH WE DO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AS FAR AS THE SCHOOL BONDS WE DO
SUPPORT THE ONE POINT.
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS I'M TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THAT SO
THANK YOU I KNOW MY TIME IS UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
JERRY SHELTON ON BEHALF OF QUE
ROB THE ASSOCIATION OF CAREER IN
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS.
THE SAN BERNARDINO DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR OUR BETTER SCHOOLS
THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCATION.
I VERY BRIEF COMMENTS JUST TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE INTENDED
ACTION WITH RESPECT TO K. TWELVE
C. T. E. FUNDS WERE FIRMLY IN
SUPPORT OF MR O'DONNELL'S BILL
A. B. THIRTEEN OH THREE AND WILL
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S ACTIONS GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ERICA HOW OFTEN I'LL BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION I WILL KEEP THIS
VERY SHORT -- I WILL ALIGN
MYSELF WITH JERRY'S COMMENTS
JUST NOW ON THE SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN OH THREE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS AND
ALSO OF YOUR COMMENTS WITH
REGARDS.
TO THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
BOND SOLD -- UNDER SCHOOL
FACILITIES AT A MUCH FASTER RATE
IN ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF THE
BACKLOG IT'S CURRENTLY PENDING --
AND ON SPECIAL ED WE I WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
THOUGH WITH THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT WE
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING THE
GOVERNOR'S PUT IN THE BUDGET.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT AND
CHILL AND UNLESS WE CAN FULLY
FUND AND APPROPRIATELY FUND
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
WE'RE STILL GONNA BE CHASING THE
SAME CIRCLE OVER AND OVER SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MORNING MICHELLE MCANDREW
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- LIKE MANY OTHER
OTHER COMMENTS WERE VERY GLAD --
FOR THE ATTENTION TO STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES IT HAS BEEN
WELL OVER A DECADE SINCE THERE'S
BEEN ANY MEANINGFUL ADDITIONS OR
SO GRATEFUL TO BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION BUT LIKE MANY THE
OTHERS WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
STRUCTURE OF AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT
WE ARE A CO SPONSOR --
EQUALIZATION WE THINK IS THE
EQUITY ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED THIS YEAR -- AND INTO
THE FUTURE AND WHILE NOT
EVERYONE WOULD RECEIVE FUNDING
UNDER THE EQUALIZATION METHOD --
THERE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR PRESCHOOL AND WE
KNOW THAT SUCH A SMART
INVESTMENT FOR THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS THAT GET ZERO DOLLARS
RIGHT NOW FROM THE STATE SO --
VERY SUPPORTIVE AGAIN OF AB FOR
TWENTY EIGHT AND HOPE THAT THAT
IS THE STRUCTURE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER FOR THE
STATE BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M JOHN JACOBS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR STOCK
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M A
SINGLE DISTRICTS CELL PLAN I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE FACTS OF YOU KNOW
WHAT THE AB FOR TWENTY WOULD
MEAN FOR OUR DISTRICT.
SO WE SERVE ALL RIGHT OFF FORTY
ONE STUDENTS FORTY ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS OUR THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND SO ARE FUNDING WHICH RANGES
FROM THE STATE TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS TO NINE
THIRTY STALKING IF I ONLY
RECEIVED FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
DOLLARS PER ADA.
SO THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EQUALIZATION REALLY HELP OUT ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS WE SERVE THE
NEEDIEST COMMUNITY WE HAVE 85%
OF OUR STUDENTS ARE LOW
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS.
AND SO WE ARE ALSO SEE AN INFLUX
OF MORRIS FAMILIES MOVING INTO
OUR AREA IS TALKING UNIFIED SO.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE'RE
SEEING MORE MORE HIGH NEED
STUDENTS WITH HIGH COST SERVICES
THAT WE ARE PROUD TO PROVIDE AND
PROVIDE INCLUSIVE EDUCATION.
PRACTICING OUTCOMES BUT WE DID
WE HAD DEFINITELY NEED THE
FUNDING ALSO WE SEE AT A GREAT
INCREASE IN STUDENTS WITH AUTISM
ESPECIALLY IN THE PRESCHOOL SO
WE'D REALLY APPRECIATE TO SEIZE
THE MORE SPECIALIZED FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL.
AS WE TRY TO MOVE OUR STUDENTS
TO OUR PROGRAMS AND PLACED BACK
INTO JENNETTE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA BE SOLANO
COUNTY SELF ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT AND PARENT OF A
CHILD WITH DISABILITIES AND
ECHOING MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
I'M IN SUPPORT OF MEDINA'S PLAN
UNDER A BEFORE.
TWENTY EIGHT IN IS PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL FOR MY REGION AS WERE
FUNDED JUST LIKE STOCKTON AT
ABOUT THE BOTTOM QUARTER OF
SELFLESS.
THAT PUTS A LOT OF COST DRIVERS
ON OR ELSE EFF FUNDING FOR OUR
REGULAR SCHOOL OPERATIONS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT AND JUSTICE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THE HIGH
COST NEEDS -- FUNDING IS IS
CRUCIAL WE HAVE THE CLOSURE OF
THE CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
DIRECTLY IMPACTING OUR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH THE
OPENING OF TO CRISIS HOMES.
THE SUMMER AND OUR REGIONAL
CENTER WHICH COVER CINEMA NAPA
AND SOLANO COUNTY.
OPENING ADDITIONAL HOMES IN
SOLANO COUNTY BECAUSE IT'S THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE WE'RE
EXPECTING FOR HOMES FOR STUDENTS
WITH PROFOUND DISABILITIES TO
OPEN IN ONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
OVER THE SUMMER.
WHICH I ANTICIPATE COULD BE AN
ADDITIONAL MILLION DOLLARS WITH
THE PRIVATE SERVICES FOR KIDS.
AND LASTLY WE ARE OPENING
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS FOR PRESCHOOL
STUDENTS NEXT YEAR FOR INTENSIVE
TREATMENT OF KIDS WITH AUTISM.
AND THERE'S NO FUNDING FOR THAT
SO FUNDING FOR PRESCHOOL IS ALSO
CRITICAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION -- JUST WANT TO MAKE
A FEW COMMENTS FIRST OF ALL --
WE WERE BOTH ENCOURAGED BUT ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THE DATA
THAT WE HEARD HERE TODAY.
THE THAT THERE'S INCREASE MEANT
INCREASING ENROLLMENT ON C. T.
PROGRAMS BUT IT'S VERY MODEST --
THAT THERE'S CONTINUED INTEREST
IN USING THOSE FUNDS.
TO DEVELOP PROGRAMS EXPAND
PROGRAM STILL THOSE IN THOSE
REQUESTS ARE OUTPACING THE NEED
FOR THE FUNDING ALMOST DOUBLE --
AND THEN ALSO TO THE POINT THAT
YOU RAISED MISTER CHAIR THAT THE
USE OF THOSE FUNDS ME ONLY
MARGINALLY BE GETTING INTO THE
CLASSROOM -- CALVARY MANY
FACTORS WE SUPPORT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL'S AB
THIRTEEN OH THREE BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES MORE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR CAREER TECH EDUCATION HAS WE
ARE HERE EVERY YEAR TESTIFYING.
IN SUPPORT OF IT ALSO MOVES THE
PROGRAM BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT
BUT IT ALSO EQUALLY IMPORTANT.
PROVIDES DIRECTION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PROFESSIONAL
TECHNICAL STAFF TO SUPPORT WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF CREATION OF
THOSE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT
AND HELP WITH INDUSTRY
ENGAGEMENT.
I KNOW THAT TODAY THAT WERE
HAVING A FISCAL DISCUSSION BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
ADDITIONAL POLICY DISCUSSIONS.
TO ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE
WORKABLE THAT THEIR FUNCTIONAL
THAT THEY'RE OF HIGH QUALITY AND
THAT THE RELEVANT AND KEEPING
PACE WITH THE JOB NEEDS THAT WE
SEE.
AND THEIR RESPECTIVE REGIONS SO
THE STATE RECEIVES MORE THAN A
MODEST RETURN ON ITS INVESTMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH BROWN WITH
CHILDREN NOW SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
RECOGNIZED ON ONLY THE NEED FOR
MORE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUT ALSO MORE
IMPORTANTLY AROUND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND SCHOOL SCHOOL
READINESS AND TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT.
SO WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE
HERE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND LOOK FOR TO A
MORE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AROUND HOW
TO BEST UTILIZE NEW FUNDING --
PARTICULARLY RUN EARLY
INTERVENTION AND SCHOOL
READINESS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN KEVIN FOR THE
LAST WORDS OF THIS MEETING YOU
MIGHT SAY -- I DO OFFERS SUPPORT
I DO YOU OFFER IS DIRECTLY SEEN
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE CRATER
NEEDS -- SOMEWHERE YOU NEED
THOUGH TO ALSO IN THE RESPECT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU NEED TO DETERMINE HOW SOON
YOU CAN MAKE ASSESSMENTS OF
CHILDREN I HAVE NOT SEEN MUCH GO
ON THAT THAT'S PROBABLY MORE A
POLICY BUT IT IS A FISCAL NEED.
TO DO A SOONER SS BUT NOT
PERFORMANCE BUT ASSESSMENT AND
EVALUATION BECAUSE CRITICALLY
NOW AND ESPECIALLY SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S PUSHING MUCH MORE
YOUNGER CHILD RICH OCCASION.
THEY NEED TO BE A VALUED AND
ASSESSED SOONER THAN WAITING
TILL THIRD GRADE TO GET SOME
FORM OF ASSESSMENT OF HOW THEY
ARE DOING -- BUT THAT'S NOT PART
OF THIS COMMITTEE BUT I BRING IT
TO YOUR ATTENTION AS YOUR
LAUGHED WORDS.
OF AND THAT OTHER WAY THAN.
OF COLLEGE EDUCATION WHAT GETS
MORE JOBS OUT THERE IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT THAT
CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING WILL
ADJOURN